i don't even know where to start with
you
so i'm just going to start do it because
i am completely obsessed with you
blown away by you you are the only
person in the zeitgeister artist that
myself and my chief of staff grace both
agree
is brilliant
oh thank you
usually
we don't agree on anything
like you are the one person like she's
amazing the music videos are brilliant
thank you so means a lot i i i it should
because we together like no one
but there's so many things i want to
talk about because you know your music
does this thing and your and your work
as i've watched your short films i want
to talk about as well yeah i'm gonna
talk about your movie um and everything
but
your music does this thing where it
gives a sound and gives words to
emotions that are impossible to explain
and that are embarrassing and just like
it's there's just no way to describe
those feelings and you you did it
and that's so impressive to me it's so
cathartic for me it's so um
uh
you know it's weird you remind me of you
know
and i dare say you might be the only
artist that i know of today i'm sure
there are ones that i i'm not like hip
enough to get okay i know lionel richie
um
that that remind me of the artists you
know and these are just the ones for me
that whether it's by chance or whatever
the ones that gave me
permission to be human and sticky and
what our society likes to call messy if
you have any human emotions or need to
cope with the uh trauma people like to
say you're messy yeah if you're
authentic and open about just
the uh very normal struggles of every
human being um uh
you remind me of um i hope i hope this
lands is because this is the highest
compliment i can give anyone so
hopefully this lands well tori amos and
atlantis morissette were the first
musicians i heard that made it cool i
love to have feelings and anger and be
jealous and be scared and be hurt and it
was the first time i was like oh no
that's cool yeah
i love that it makes me super happy to
hear i mean i
atlantis morissette i remember when i
was you know a kid and and started to
understand english since i'm swedish
and i was just like oh but she's saying
like bad things about herself you know
that was kind of like something that
stuck with me and i remember
growing up that i would prefer to
listen to music that would just talk
about
how i was feeling not how to fix it not
try to escape from it not try to hide it
and i think that became
something that was like cathartic to me
to write just like this is what is going
on this is what i'm
these are my flaws just kind of being
honest about an emotion even though it's
embarrassing like you said like that is
um
something that like helps me just as a
as an emotional kind of messy person um
when i write to just be honest about
those feelings and and
i didn't realize that you know there
would be so many people out there who
felt the same way you know but there
always is you know and so that was kind
of um
yeah that's that's kind of when i got
like when i started writing you never
think about like when you write your
first album you have your whole life to
write your first album and so you never
think about that you know
um anyone's gonna hear it really when
you write your first song so you just
kind of you know you're in your own head
and you're you're um making music for
yourself kind of like writing in a diary
or something exactly exactly so
um but then when i put my first album
out i don't think i really realized how
personal it was until
it was out and i was like everybody
knows so much about me now that i wasn't
ready to share
and but then it kind of really
was an amazing experience so i just kind
of kept being like just what no matter
what you do just be honest in your songs
and that's kind of yeah and you say
messy and i'm obsessed with these words
that are used to pathologize people
because to me they're always so off like
you know when you use crazy psycho stuff
like this especially about women or
anyone that shows emotions to me it's so
much messier to bottle up your emotions
and then so that they crystallize into
some other feeling and then you just
snap on somebody completely out of
nowhere that is so much messier people
that don't
resolve and allow grace to enter the
room by
um
admitting your deepest darkest things
you're supposed to be ashamed about yeah
those to me are the most graceful open
and free when i think of you i just
think like this this person is so free
to not have secrets and to not be hiding
anything that is like the epitome of
freedom
and then obviously you're being so
wildly rewarded for it you know what i
mean that must be kind of like a nice
thing to just yeah i mean that's that's
the thing it's like it was such um i
mean i never i feel like i would have
been happy with so much
less you know i also think maybe because
people think of pop music or like when i
started i would say because it's been
been a few years now um
that it was
supposed to be popular was like an
escape from things that were ugly and
sad like you would listen to a pop song
and that would make you happy you could
forget about your problems but then
i think
i kind of um
came in on this wave of new artists who
were writing pop songs but very kind of
dark and sad and like admitting to their
flaws and their problems and and
speaking openly about making mistakes
and being you know i remember that first
year i would get so many like why are
you such a bad girl i'm like ooh i'm a
bad girl like what are you talking about
like this is not you know and i guess
also
maybe the culture difference being
sweden stop flirting
why are you such a bad girl
i know why are you so obsessed with me
it was so so such a weird like don't you
feel like you should set a better
example for young girls and i'm like
i don't know i'm just being me
they made all your flaws and make
millions of dollars i cannot think of a
better way to set an example for women
moving forward make every breakup uh buy
you a house yeah exactly exactly you're
in your heartbreak you can do it you can
do it um no but but i think that was
like uh it was a bit of like if i could
notice that it bothered
um certain people how like
that i was kind of proud and open about
you know
sides to me that i shouldn't brag about
you know what i mean like it kind of
like that i shouldn't be talking about
even as a woman was this in sweden or
just in america i would say mainly
america yeah
i love it here welcome
our dna is riddled with guilt and shame
um no but i would say but the i think
sweden would have
so we don't have way more problems with
the sort of me i mean me talking about
me doing like a weed drink now like
collaboration with a wee drink is like
they're like
it's very very anti any kind of drug and
so
um but but that wouldn't really get in a
reaction in the states it was like yeah
weed who cares yeah but the the
like the sex stuff and me being very
openly you know open about my sexuality
and open up being a sexual human being
swedes would be like whatever show your
titties we don't care but the states
would be like oh you just what are you
doing you know right right right that
was kind of like i only want to see your
titties if i'm cheating on my wife
paying for sex at 2 am in a cd hotel
before church
oh just like exactly
honestly i have to i was thinking about
that because i heard you in an interview
talking about like you know
whether it's america's reaction or when
people people are very triggered by sex
they're very triggered by strong women
that own their shit they're very
triggered by women that don't live in
shame
um it's very confusing to people i think
it makes people angry because it's a
type of freedom that is very hard for
people to attain it's very hard to just
look at and go oh why don't i just be
free like there's so much unraveling of
social construction and ancestral trauma
and religious dogma like there's it's
it's it's one thing to go like oh that
person has this purse i want it you can
get it exactly but the idea of i'm gonna
to rewire my brain to be as free as her
is like that is yeah and i mean maybe
it's just enough to like go to one of my
shows and have that for a night and then
you can go back to you know however you
live your life otherwise that's a
nightmare of jerking off to deep web
porn
and but i i'm thinking about you and and
this is a definitely a weird place to
start but that's my brand so i'm
thinking about your music and i think
about how um
to me that is the pinnacle of what great
art does is someone can sublimate their
heartbreak their grossest feelings their
most embarrassing moments into something
that helps other people feel less shame
about their embarrassing moments you
know and i think about sort of all of
the
hardship and that went into your music
and
my question for you is now that you're
married and happy
do you ever worry i know yeah
you're like i never said happy
am i married i forget all the time
but do you ever worry because i'm so
excited about the kind of music that
you're going to make now that you're in
a
yeah secure relationship i as a comedian
definitely worry when i'm in a happy
relationship or i don't have ostensible
drama happening all the time what am i
going to come up with i'm like can you
just cheat on me so i can get some jokes
like please but the thing is it's funny
though it's not interesting that we do
pull so much of our inspiration from
like
dark moments and like intense moments
and like passionate moments but it has
to be a little bit of like
fear or anger or like uncertainty to
like feel like you're like me being calm
is my worst nightmare like i don't like
to be
like to me that's why this like
me being like at home for a year
obviously it wasn't like a calm time at
all but
just the feeling of being in one place
and not experiencing
be having a routine with emotions and
people was super weird for me and like
kind of i had a you know a few panics
through it all like i mean and my
situation was obviously
probably a lot better than most because
i was like in a house with people i love
you know and that brings us to canada
and that makes us do why
you having a drink now
with thc in it because that was all i
did all the time so i kept staying calm
um no but but i think like i do pull a
lot from
um from kind of times in my life when i
when i've been struggling like
struggling with depression or just being
feeling unsure of anything
but i will say like my so my last album
that i put out in 2019 uh sunshine kitty
was
an album that i wrote where i felt like
i'm like happy what do i do it was
really hard for me to start writing and
i remember the first few songs that i
wrote on i was like this isn't for me
because it's really happy yeah that was
my
mindset
um but then it just kind of had to be
like you know what just roll with this
like write a few songs about happy love
you know
but i think
now like with
charlie um my husband i still can't
understand that i'm saying husband it
feels super weird um but
calm your wife yeah he's my wife
i like the word wife better actually
it's good um but we were so
like i mean i love him so much and we're
so similar we are really happy together
and it's funny that
now that i have something so special
that i'm like i really care about him
and i don't want to fuck this up
so then i start to write about all the
you know my imagination is pretty wild
so i'll just start thinking of these
scenarios so like what's the worst thing
that could happen between us and so
all of these kind of crazy fears come up
about
i'm like what if he just like isn't who
i thought he was what if he just has a
whole other
relationship or what if i did something
and so then i start writing talks about
my biggest fears yeah good good good
good and it's like a really nice way to
kind of get that those thoughts out of
the way without having to sort of
confront him about shit that i made up
that he did you know what i'm sure oh
yeah yeah i'm the queen if i wake up
from a dream and i'm like you just
cheated on me in my dream and they're
like well that wasn't i didn't
oh do you know how many times i have
those dreams but i've had like any idea
what you did to me in my dream last
night do you have any idea the way you
spoke to me i actually get mad at him
i'm like i know i'm not i'm not mad at
you he's like this is i'm not saying
you're crazy but this is crazy do you
understand that like you can't get mad
at me when i didn't do anything you're
the one that married a pop star who's
crazy now okay my crazy thoughts pay for
this house oh but it's just like
that thing where i'm like and i remember
i've had dreams where like he dies of an
inoperable brain tumor and i like wake
up crying and i'm like
oh you're still here like i have so many
weird dreams that he like somehow leaves
my life and i feel ridiculous because
i'm like i'm an independent woman like
i've made my own life like i can be on
my own like i'm good but i'm really like
attached to him
and i love that like it's really awesome
but it's just like such a funny
thing that i'm still like i'll make up
these scenarios in my head that i'm like
look out for the new hit single brain
tumor
hot club jam it was like what happened
what happened to you guys no but that's
the thing like he's heard obviously a
lot of the songs and he's like this is
great i'm just like is this about me
and i'm like not about you like this is
like potentially a scenario that could
happen to us and he's like i really hope
not like that sounds terrible and i'm
like you know you're so so vain
you're probably i mean the song is about
you
no but i i feel that i still am able to
get like maybe just because who i am i'm
driven by
emotion and just like so that would just
always be in my my life so if things are
calm i definitely feel this like i was
to come before the storm what's going to
happen next i'm not like i don't worry
but i just like i don't know i think
love is tricky man
it's a doozy
and i want to ask you this because i was
watching fire fade you're short yeah i
would like to discuss it
and but i've watched that in a while as
someone who
i believe is
um incredibly gifted obviously at
putting words
to feelings that are intangible and very
hard to convey
you know um
what is your definition of love and how
did you know you loved charlie as
someone that has expressed their
experience with lust
and you know heart all these stress what
is love i can tell you about all about
lust i know love i know love addiction i
know toxic entrenchment but love what
are we doing yeah 39 years old still
don't know
well i kind of feel
the same but i it actually got it from
i would say that love
to me is this
when when you've i don't know how do you
yeah i don't honestly i don't fucking
know but it's what i'd say it has to do
with my this tattoo happy sad i love
that because you have this feeling of
like
you know you're so
um
excited and it's like you can't believe
you found this person but then there is
that sting of like the fear of losing it
like you always they always kind of go
hand in hand a little bit so it's always
like kind of
it can be
uh passionate it can be sweet
you know but but there's still that
little bit of like
no matter how much you feel secure with
them there's always a little bit of
fear as long as you're in love that
you're going to lose it
sure and that can sometimes take over
that's what i'm eating ice cream and i'm
worried i'm going to drop it yeah that's
the
but i would say that i knew
it's so weird because i when i when i
met him
uh the first time i met him at this
after party and he had a girlfriend the
time so he just i started like kind of
hitting on him right away and he just
ran away from me he was like nope not
doing that by the way hot yeah hot so
hot yeah he paid me no attention and
you're like i am dancing
like nice to meet you but i'm out
you know and so then i didn't like
run into him and i think we had like
friends in common who were like you know
who knew that i was interested in him
and they're like i'm at a bar with
charlie don't you want to come like uh
come meet us reject it again sure and
i'm like
easy singles he's like no i'm like then
stop inviting me he's like oh i know and
like it was just like kind of which was
kind of shitty of this was like a
a kind of not a close friend to him a
closer friend to me so they were like i
know you think he's cute um but anyway
so then i uh i didn't like see him until
my birthday
like way later when's your birthday uh
october 29th oh
and i was having a release party and a
short film premiere
and like a carnival on the same night
and he came to that and then he was
single
and he kind of
came over to me and was like hey and i
was like hey oh it's you and then i
could just like sense
that like
oh he's probably out of his relationship
now
i i feel like i know why he's having
that relationship too
for 30 seconds
magically single two weeks yeah no it
was it was quite a while later actually
so i i'd kind of like forgotten about
him a bit and uh i'd been single for a
while and lived my life and then he just
kind of um
yeah it was that he was at that thing
and then we kind of started talking and
then it was just like i was like oh i'm
going to fall in love with this guy but
i'm going to try and take it slow
because i was touring the whole time it
was like constant like in a weird way it
was probably good i finally was really
good yeah when you have some kind of
structured way to be away from the
person that so you don't overdose on
them too fast it's so true i think it
helped us both a lot because he was
definitely i mean he'd been single for a
while too but he definitely wasn't ready
to be in anything like so quick so we
were it was actually
it was perfect for both of us i just
yeah it was really
um
i don't know but i just knew so early on
i was like i can probably not tell them
that i'm in love with them for like a
year i can try and do that i'm working
on this new definition of love that it's
like it doesn't matter if you say you
love me if i don't feel loved it doesn't
matter yeah so do you have the kind of
love that i can actually receive because
sometimes you're in relationships and
you're giving a type of love that they
don't understand or don't want or that's
toxic no i actually i've been in that
before where it's like
where i've been on the side of like a
person i was really into was like
but you know i just i love you i could
tell that he thought that i was gonna
say it back that it was like and i was
like i'm almost there which is like the
worst response again ever
and he was just like
what do you mean you're almost there and
he was so in shock are you gonna make
any more money in the next year
it was just so weird like
it was almost one of the most awkward
moments ever but but like so i but i
remember to charlie i just like blurted
it out before we were even a couple i
was like
but i'm in love with you so and he's
like what i'm like
how's
it means different in swedish that was
probably a translation issue
i was like
i'm not rushing you though he's like
but do you do you like want to be my
girlfriend and i'm like yeah he's like
so cute like when a guy asked you to be
his girlfriend and you think you were
their girlfriend for the last six months
you're like wait a second wait what
nobody was like so funny because we just
said like let's take it slow and then it
was just like i just blurted it out but
i was like we can still take it slow
though he was like it's kind of not now
though if you
ship his sale
but that to me is like the illest thing
to be able to just go like not overthink
it or have some kind of schedule because
that's when something's not organic if
you can't just be authentic and even
yeah say that even if you don't want to
say it back if i feel uncomfortable or
weird about if i can't say i love you to
someone i love then i certainly can't
it's not yeah it's going to be happening
well i'm gonna feel insecure yeah
exactly and i think that's why i love
our relationship is because
it's just we've done everything in the
wrong order like but we basically kind
of
but but it just feels right because
we're so honest i just know
we know each other really well i mean
we've been together for five years soon
so it's like
kind of this
i don't know it just feels very
um
we're just in tune with each other i
don't know that's fascinating
we're cutting that it makes me sad cut
whitney cut to me crying so here here's
my question so
do you ever feel weird uh you know cause
look everyone's gonna want to hear
habits when you perform and this i would
imagine as a
musician i remember one time i went saw
lauren hill at uh club nokia and
she played and i'm a massive fan and she
played all of her hits in a slightly
different way yeah you know she did a
little more reggae a little more 80s
reggae which was awesome but i did find
myself being slightly disappointed that
i couldn't sing along do you know what i
mean like that all the hits right and i
realized i was like oh as an artist you
you probably like em move past where you
move on a bit yeah but then you have to
get back into that place when you're not
in that place anymore is that awkward
when you perform that song or do you
just go i'm also an actress and i can
get back in there yeah like is it weird
to do around him
no i feel like i can
i can kind of tap back into those
emotions or it's like a different
emotion but it's kind of similar state
of mind you know i feel like i can
it's also for me like that song
specifically has given me so much it
changed my life so i'm always a bit
emotional performing it so
it might be like in you know in a
happier sad way like you know a happier
emotional way but
i feel like
it
like it still hasn't been
a point where i'm like oh not this song
again i'm not at this place anymore but
but what i do is i will kind of kind of
change up
i'll keep my like
my kind of biggest songs the way that
they are
and then i might do sort of like a like
a kind of rave dance number after like
talking body i'll do this kind of dance
section after so we'll do the song like
it is and then go into like a dance
section that's kind of based on the song
like there's so many amazing remixes of
that song so we kind of go into one of
those sort of parts after so i like to
do that but i usually keep the songs
that i know
people are the most like hooked on the
same and then i kind of like mess up the
outro or like do something new with a
song that maybe isn't as big so it kind
of feels like what's that you know right
because the hardcore fans are like they
know every single word every ad-lib
every single little detail you know
they're like clap in the one spot that
there's like a little break and it's
just like it's really
it's incredible i want to they're paying
to come see me so i want to blow their
minds but i also want to make sure that
they
like
are given what they want you know
why did you wear a wolf shirt in the
video
i'm obsessed oh the
the habits video yes
honestly
i
don't like that's mine no
that's your thing that i just didn't
like i was like
as well and we have i'm wearing an alien
earring you're wearing an alien necklace
i guess i just feel like we're besties
no big deal i think i guess you just
have to be mine
i'd come back over like was there i'm
just so curious your your fashion i
never have never talked to
anyone that's been on this podcast about
their choice of clothes i've literally
never talked about it never talked about
i don't care about fashion i don't care
no but you make choices that are so
um
and this is why you're i believe going
to be a very great filmmaker if you want
to do that if that's something that does
appeal to you because in your short
films i see the way you tell a story
visually is so
important and i don't even know if it's
by accident or intentional
but the choices that you make uh even
with just like sometimes you're doing
the sexiest thing in like granny panties
and i'm like what kind of genius
picked those panties are those from rite
aid like where like everything it's like
the eye shadow and the perfect hair and
the perfect this and the tank top and
then granny panties like hanes they're
like baggy and it's hotter than any
lingerie you could have pegged i love
that no i have to give um a lot of
credit to my stylist annie and hannah
who are two girls that i've worked with
pretty much from day one
and they
just like get this sort of like
sexy with some humor and kind of like
boyish vibes sometimes which i feel
like because when i started i was like i
was i did not care about fashion i hated
fashion i hated getting my hair done i
hate getting my makeup done so i was
like no no no no no less like i remember
my first
my first tv performance in the states
was seth meyers
and
i remember i got this like um it was
like a cute black outfit
and i had these kind of like boots on
and i was supposed to go out and i was
like i can't wear these shoes i have to
be barefoot everyone's like no don't be
barefoot on tv
your management goes here we go
and i'm like you the blue m m's i was
like i can't do it and i just like
kicked them off and really easy and seth
meyers this is not the show
to to go diva on don't go
no i just kicked them off and i just ran
out and it was just like and i felt
really like grounded and i think like
annie and hannah came on really early on
after that and they just kind of like
there's like okay so you want to be able
to move easily you want to be
comfortable but then it needs to have
some like kind of grunge and edge and so
it's kind of just evolved from that i've
gotten way more interested in
fashion i kind of realized that like oh
it's it's just like a way to express
myself further so i kind of played into
it like that but
i have no idea about designers i've no
idea about
brands but they're really good at like
finding cool like kind of younger
designers and then like a lot of vintage
pieces i try to like do a lot of vintage
stuff so it just feels so um
it never feels styled
no it never feels pre-packaged it never
feels there's like a rawness and a grit
to it that is just like perfect and it
makes me
feel way closer to you than i should
because i'm like oh i love that you know
like it's like it's just it's it's it's
so well done it's so impeccable and i
also think in terms of the way you move
when you when you perform there's such a
primal
sort of carnal energy and like not being
restricted is that like also a part of
it very much yeah i think if i i mean i
never have
makeup and hair on tour because i get
sometimes when i get like
because i don't need it i don't need it
i'm not good at doing it
but i just i basically just like make my
hair messy and smear some glitter on and
then i go because then i just get sweaty
after two songs and it's just all kind
of and i just and i have to feel if i'm
like wait how's the hair laying i need
to make sure i just get i panic like
it's like that's why i think
that tv performances can be really hard
because i think they're hard to feel raw
and feel like kind of yes you know
because you
you're literally there for like eight
hours and they do you know you're so
styled and fixed and then you go out and
do this performance in three minutes and
it's freezing so you don't have the time
to kind of always freeze it down they do
that on purpose yeah and so i feel like
to see what it takes
exactly they say it's to keep the
audience awake but to see nipples but
then they make you cover the nipples so
trust me i've tried to like no bra and
they're like you need to wear a bra
we can't see nipples but it's through a
shirt is that's the case on network
television why do you hate ratings you
wonder why all your shows are failing
and why podcasts are doing well
that's wild no but i feel like it's
because it's like um
i mean it's obviously like i always have
had like good experience like everyone's
super nice and everything but i just for
me as a performer it's still a it's a
challenge too it took me like four or
five two performances to get to a point
i'm like okay this is what i got to do
to really get through the screen because
i would look at the performance after
and i'm like
i look great and my band is playing
great and like the lights are great but
i just look
terrified and like is this even right
like am i singing yeah yeah well i mean
you're also performing for a bunch of
people that are that have been bused in
from orlando that thought they were
going to prices right and
they're like who is she yeah like how do
i say her name i don't even understand
who she heard as a fan to figure out how
to go see your favorite artist yeah
you know what i mean like you have to go
away you know i think your fans are too
cool
to yeah they're they're not going to be
on seat filler.com or wherever i don't
even know how they get these people off
of the like the the warner brothers like
tour bus
i was a tourist in new york when i was
like 20 and i was like can we go to
letterman
that was cool actually i that was like a
cause letterman would uh air in sweden
too so like that was someone that i knew
and i was like whoa this is cool
yeah but i don't know it's it's been
like those kind of things if i compared
to like the i prefer like the sweaty
rawness of like a festo show or a sweaty
club show where you really can just
sweat on a tv sound stage it's
impossible you're like a lizard you're
so dehydrated it's impossible but then
you're sweating so much under your pits
yes and nowhere else yes just pitching
and i have to make sure to adapt the
outfit after that because i've had some
moments where i'm like about to go on
stage and was like oh my god no you
literally have circles down like like
not great
yeah yeah you're scared in all the wrong
places it is such a bummer it is that is
such an art
to get a tv appearance right no
experience on the stage not on the mic
and you're just like oh this is a
totally new skill
you know i don't like bowling alleys i
can play arenas but like this is so
awkward it's so and i like
i don't yeah i don't know what it is but
it's something about it doesn't matter
how like
nice and like everyone is trying to make
you comfortable you just feel out of
place i don't know what it is yeah
because it's a very um superficial
environment where a lot of people that
aren't artists are trying to
uh be of service to artists when you're
like the only thing i really need is for
it to be 10 p.m
so stop trying to help me it has to be a
controlled environment and that's not
what we work best in
exactly yeah exactly and like we need a
little chaos to feed off of a little
danger you know there's no danger being
the crowd i'm always like is there an
audience oh they're they're there
they're so far away
oh and they're all in like tommy bahama
and they're just like where's ellen
they're so confused
i've been through that so many times
they don't even know that they're
allowed to be involved they're just
trying to win a pontiac i mean they're
they're in a win i'm sure they're also
like a bit scared because you're like
they're on tv like i'm on tv and they're
like what do i do with my hands so like
you clap
with your hands and it's like
yeah they're all just staring into the
camera i mean half of the shots you
cannot even use because the camera goes
by and they're just they think it's
their moment yeah yeah they're like oh
no no people are going to tune in to
watch her sing but they're going to see
the reaction out of me and be like yeah
i gotta put him in the pictures like
they're it's my moment
um but i i i i'm just gonna say this now
because i'm gonna get out of the way and
i know you've talked about robin being
you know one of your inspirations and
yes very much i i'm annoyed that i heard
you say that in an interview because
she's the only person
that you really remind me of like in
terms of your i hope this comes off okay
your bravery as a performer and you're
abandoned as a performer
that that i mean to me i think the best
live performance ever is her on snl when
she did call your girlfriend and she's
doing backflips on the stage and there's
just a
rawness that is like gives you chills
it's just so cool that like i've been
a fan of her since i was like since the
first time i started like listening to
music like and i she's my mind her yeah
and i just find her so she's so much
integrity she's so like
fierce and just like
and her songs they do that like what
makes me so happy that you say that i do
to you she does to me like she just
really puts words to
all the little details of
feelings and she can use like sort of
very
everyday
like
scenarios and make them sound so big and
dramatic and emotional you know what i
mean yeah but they just it feels like at
the time it does feel like that when
you're in the club and he's flirting
with another girl
but you did this with um uh the song you
did with kylie minogue i i hate i don't
like you i just don't like it i really
don't like you you
really capture that that that pit in
your stomach when you like see the guy
with the and you're in the only thing to
do is not like her yeah that's what you
know what i can do and it's like a
that's one of those songs
but that would be dumb yeah so i it just
has to be your fault so i can get
through this sorry girl and i think
that's the thing it's like that's a
feeling that you know is like wrong and
kind of ugly but it's just what everyone
feels you can't help yourself you just
judge the way we cope you don't you
don't judge the way we cope like you
have such a um
healthy relationship with human nature
and i'm curious because i feel like the
best artists sometimes haven't only done
what they do and i'm really interested
in what working at urban outfitters
and as a coat check girl because i think
a lot of people listening that want to
be comedians that want to be musicians
are like but i work at you know made
well i work here like everything is an
artist that you've ever done the most
boring jobs yeah anything where you're
exposed to a lot of people and the worst
sides of them because in retail i bet
you're seeing the worst sides of people
what did that teach you about human
nature
what did it just drive you to be like i
need to freaking make it as a singer i
could get out of here i would say
actually
urban outfitters were was kind of um i
think the job where i saw like
the worst kind of like like how people
can be was when i worked in
right after high school i started
working at this um bakery in this kind
of like fancy area outside of stockholm
and i would start at like 6 00 in the
morning they would deliver like daily
fresh bread and i would just like make
coffee and you know serve sandwiches and
like sell bread
and the people that came through
were just like
it was one of those like people who
suppressed their feelings and decided to
take it all out of me in the morning
before work which is what you do if you
don't just say
you know that's what you do and some
people call that's what i say is messy
that's messy that's messy because you're
not you're not emotionally hygienic i
will never forget i would like had
started i can't i think i came like i
was 15 minutes late so i didn't turn the
lights on yet but i still opened on time
and this guy comes in
uh and he's like you know businessman in
his 50s maybe and he's like
hey did you open late this morning i'm
like oh no we opened on time and he's
like okay because i usually jog by
around like 6 30 and the lights are on
and the lights weren't on i'm like oh
yeah no the i was like maybe i turned
the lights on late but i opened i opened
at seven as usual and he's like
okay because um
i just want to say like you know i work
in marketing and it's pretty you know
that's like a nice thing for me to feel
like the homeless of you being here and
like having the lights on when i go for
my morning jog and i was like
and i'm like 19 or something at a time
and i'm like
okay
so what do you say saying like i should
turn the lights on for you before we're
open
like is that what you want me to do and
he's like
i want to speak to your manager
i'm like
excuse me like you're being really like
rude and unreasonable i'm like i'm being
rude and unreasonable okay hang on and
like go and get like the manager i was
like hey can you talk to him so he feels
i opened on time today at seven but he
feels because i hadn't didn't have the
lights on at 6 30 that that was like bad
you know
that was you know i was not being um a
good i don't know like that wasn't good
for him as a customer even though we
weren't open yet like that experience
for him was bad that the lights weren't
on
and she was like looked at him and she's
like sir are you serious and he's like
oh you and then you just like took off
on us like us like how can you know like
and that's when i started dating women
yeah exactly
no but it was just that like he was so
he i could see in his eyes like he was
so mad at me and then the fact that my
manager was a woman was also like really
frustrating to him and she we were both
younger than him and we how could we be
so disrespectful to him like he's a
successful man he can take away all of
our business like all that was starting
to happen i was like dude i just make
coffee here like i don't care like i'm
i'm like this is not my place like i
don't know like i'm not this isn't my
startup no
yes it's obviously not my dream no and
it's it was just like and that would
just happen so often that they would
just like kind of
to pick you know
wanted to like maybe have a moment of
feeling superior and then when he didn't
get that he would just like they would
just go off on us like yeah it would be
superior if you're already in the power
position like someone's paid
to not retort like like saying like i'm
and i was being i wasn't being like i
didn't i wasn't like i was being nice
you know i was being like okay um well
that just doesn't make sense like if i
open on time i'm sorry like i you know i
was like but i was also like i'm not
apologizing to this man like no way i'm
just thrilled to know there are mentally
ill people in stockholm because i
have been there and everyone was so well
adjusted and it made me a noise
and let me ask you just in terms of
your um
you know you you've talked in a couple
interviews about the importance of you
know collaborating in the beginning you
obviously like write music for other
people i think you know the states has a
very
singular mentality when it comes to
creating i want to do all the work i
want to create all the credit you know
my mind mine and when i went to
stockholm to perform people were trying
to explain to me the culture they were
like there's not as much they're more
humble like no one's proud of a
hierarchy like boss is dressed the same
as the employees like everyone's equal
even if they're not and i remember being
like i can't understand that
but the way that there is this um
ability to share and then everybody wins
is just like a mentality obviously now
you're solo and don't need anyone but is
that a specifically because so much good
music comes out of there it has to be
that yeah i mean i definitely feel that
there's
there's a way of like
i think it's like there's there's um
perks too and there's also like you know
with everything there's like some side
so that makes it like a bit harder
you're not even allowed to be proud of
yourself sometimes it's a bit stupid
like if i say in a swedish interview and
i'm like yeah i'm good at singing
they're like oh aren't you cocky and
you're like what i can't say that i'm a
good singer why would well then you're
bad at booking guests yeah like why
would i be here if i was bad at it
what's this show no i i can't remember
it was like an interview with someone um
it was a long time ago but but i
um but i just gendered it all or is that
ever across the board i think that's
across the board yeah but i feel like
there's definitely more like um like
when i think about my team that i tour
with i because my my my touring team is
like half american half swedish and i
could feel the american part of my team
having a bit of an issue with how
this my band and my monitor guy like how
they would how we would discuss things
and they'll be like and i'm like hey
guys can we start with this song and
they would go actually can we still have
some work to do on this song would you
mind coming back in a minute when we
finished i'm like yeah sounds good and
i'll just leave and they're like what
are you doing if she wants a soundcheck
now she's got a soundcheck now like you
can't just tell her to leave those are
the americans yeah and i'm like yes they
can like this is a team like if they
have stuff to work on they're american
they hate women they want me out here
so that they don't murder or rape me i
have to get out of here no sorry the
sweet the swedes were the ones telling
me to come back so it's more of like a
they are not just because i'm the the
boss they're not like
scared to tell me their opinions like
it's very like you just kind of
i guess yeah more collaborative and you
kind of say
yeah it's sort of more of a unit exactly
i obviously don't want to like
um i try to do what's best for the whole
team even if it means like something is
slightly more annoying for me like that
doesn't bother me like i'm not always
trying to make sure that i have it the
best all the time um
but there is like and i think just in
general like when i talk about my team
i'm like i work with them they don't
work for me like just just because of
the
i could never do any of this without
them like me alone
this is just a music this is a music
thing it's a music thing
no but i feel that like if i didn't have
any of them the people i write with the
people that play with me the people that
like you know i could not live a day
without laura my manager like i would
just be so lost so
it's really important to me that
everyone feels like
seen and appreciated but i also
like yeah i don't know it is a bit of
like a more kind of kind of sensitivity
towards how people are feeling in their
place of work it's not like be grateful
that you're here it's like yeah yeah
yeah
um because i'm just curious about sort
of your development as someone that's
that's
sensitive in a good way that is is like
an insult reset the words like ambitious
insensitive and vigilant and like all of
a sudden i have bad connotations
like some weird socially constructed
thing i think being sensitive is such a
superpower but i think as a woman it's
been like you know being sensitive is
what she's very sensitive
yeah that's what kept us alive as a
species two thousand years ago the most
sensitive people were the ones that were
the safest that were like that's a lion
i need to get out of here now it's just
like let me look at your phone who's
that bitch you know it's
but we i think of it as like a super
power you know but but
i'm just curious just because you know
everyone that listens knows i'm obsessed
with ancestral trauma like what in this
in swedish culture is there any kind of
like
inherited ancestral like limitations you
feel like or benefits just from well i
feel so there's this one thing called
yant the logan which basically means
that
uh there's not a word for it in english
but it kind of means like
don't
think that you're ever better than
anyone else which is like
you know that's a good thing there's no
words
it does not compute
what do you mean
i'm better than everyone um no but but
it kind of can turn into like don't even
think that you're good at all so it kind
of becomes like
you're not ever
like it's it's almost like you know what
i love about living here is that like
everyone's very supportive of your
dreams if i'm like yeah i want to go to
this i was like that's awesome you know
what i have a friend who does this and
like people are always trying to move
each other forward and even if it's like
a you know
a way that like you sort of uh gain from
it too there's still like
people are positive towards your dreams
and you're being ambitious rewarded and
yeah whereas maybe in sweden it's a bit
more like well that's not realistic you
really think you're gonna like just like
back off a little bit like that's that's
a little bit talking about yourself that
way is a little bit like you're being a
bit full of yourself basically
so so there's like a bit of kind of and
if someone becomes like being too
successful or being like um
uh
enjoying things too much like kind of
living in excess or just like it's like
you're supposed to be a little bit more
restrained and like kind of you need to
punish yourself before you can enjoy
something like you know you need to go
for a really long run before you can
have a cinnabon like you can't just like
this is all very kinky very
and i think i don't know if it has to do
with like you know a lot of the months
are there you have to ask your boyfriend
if you can have
two string beans for dinner i'm very
interested it's okay
no it's and i think that's kind of like
uh there i think there's a lot of like
you know you're kind of in touch with
darkness and like
dark emotions and like being sort of um
i don't know yeah there's like a
harshness kind of sometimes that even
though people are very nice and sort of
you know
um there's definitely like this um
kind of punishment culture a little bit
interesting that's really fascinating i
i'm always at least i feel that it's
that way yeah i'm always
fascinated by the biological basis for
these kind of feelings we have and i
think about sweden and the ancestry of
it maybe it's because everyone's so
gorgeous there's there's got to be some
way to keep egos in check i don't know
what it is maybe that's good
any swedish guy knew how hot they were
life would be a nightmare they'd all be
like genghis khans
um
that is true like they still have
because there's so many of them they do
have to have charm because they can't
just get away from being yes because
they all look like nazis it's awkward
they have to figure out a way
it is a bit like weird when like now
it's also living here and then i go back
home and obviously this sweet stockholm
is pretty much culture like but it's
still not even close to here obviously
but coming to certain areas in sweden
i'm like
wow everyone really looks like just like
a viking oh like it's like it's like
blonde like
red or like sometimes it's really really
tan but like bright blue eyes and like
really tall and just like it's
uncomfortable it's like you're like this
is what hitler wanted this is this is
what he was going for this is what he
wanted here it is i get that we're all
literally
it's uncomfortable it's like too much
this isn't this isn't all we should have
really this feels weird but i remember i
sent the world
i went over when i performed in sweden
it was it was so mind-blowing because i
remember i was working on this um what i
was doing what were you doing there i
was performing i was doing stand up this
was maybe five years ago and i was
i well before i went over i had this um
interview with some radio guy it was
like norway sweden finland amsterdam it
was just like all like scandinavia and
i'm on the phone with some journalists
and i he was like what are you gonna
talk about i remember just going like i
don't know i'm probably gonna go to some
of the strip clubs get some jokes and
then go and he was like oh you know
bergen so i was going bergen norway we
don't have strip clubs and i was like oh
my god you guys are so repressed yeah
religious what is this calvinism i was
like what is that why can't you have
strip clubs and why don't you happen
he goes um oh no actually the the
citizens don't want one they they
erected a sorry for that word i've never
used that word to describe putting a
bill
putting a building up until i was
talking about a strip club
they put a strip club in and the
the people shut it down they didn't want
it they and i was like i don't
understand what so what is this some
kind of prank and he goes oh no just
over here uh we respect women
and i was like does not compute
and i was like who's this smart ass and
then i go over there and i was doing
some joke about like it was a lot about
i was in relations with guys that were
being disrespectful and that were just
not equals and i was recreating my
childhood circumstances by being with
malignant narcissists and people that
just undervalued me and so i
was doing this joke about like when
you're fighting with a guy and he hangs
up on you a guy cheats on you then hangs
up on you and it was bombing like it was
just bombing and it kills everywhere in
the states and then i started being like
why is this bombing and i'm like oh they
must not speak good english i'm like are
you having trouble understanding and
they're like we speak perfect english uh
what are you talking about all of us
and then there was like this group of
women in the front row and i was like
single ladies are we single ladies
they're like no we're we're married and
i was like oh well where are your
husbands they're like at home i'm like
bye like like oh they're they're
watching the kids i'm like
what like i was like i don't understand
this
and then afterwards these women came up
to me and they were like hey those jokes
really funny it's just that guys don't
treat us like that over here no
like no i'm like no one's been hung up
on
never ever i know like it was just like
this thing where i was like i don't
think i've ever been hung up on i've
dated some some dicks but not like that
like i will say like
sweden has you know like our we have you
know
paternity leave is the thing like you
see you see as many like fraternity
leave in our days yeah your dad leaves
when you're born we have that too all
comedians have that
catch up
no but it's like you know it's it's
really like i mean i have like the
songwriting collective that i'm assigned
to it's like um there's a few um girls
but they're a lot younger and then
there's like um
a group of guys that are a couple years
older than me and they are now they all
within maybe two months of each other
all had babies at the same time
and they're all like you know taking
half of the time with their kids
and it's very like no no i need a the
session needs to be done at six because
i'm putting my son to bed like they're
very very
involved and it's very like
i think in sweden now too like you have
to share you get one year off and you
have to when you have a game yeah and
then both the mom and the dad have to
take time off to be with kids but you
can divide it can you how you want elect
to not if you want to not be with your
kids yeah yeah you can do that take it
you don't have to but it's like most
people want to because it's like the
first year that they want to be with
their kid yeah well i was thinking about
you because you know i think in comedy
and i think in art in general there is
this
unfortunately it's a myth uh because you
are the outlier and the exception um is
going to be the rule on this one of that
you have to have a messed up childhood
you have to have had a horrible life and
you very
clearly will just be like i had all my
needs met my life was good i was loved
yeah whereas i think that even when
people do have you know come from
stable backgrounds they feel they need
to be like yeah but like my mom she
would like read all the time
and you're like
yeah totally like they would like go on
take us on trips and we'd be in separate
penthouses and you're like okay i feel
like you're just trying to be screwed up
when you're not and i think there's
something so
inspiring to me about you of this thing
of like no i'm just this is creativity
and this is my gift i don't i'm not i
don't have all this because i was
injured before it's true
doesn't only have to come from trauma
and i feel like i i definitely was like
you know but but it's like so many
people are like i was just you know i
was a messy teenager i had like you know
moments of depression growing up but it
was never because of like nothing in my
surroundings kind of did that to me i
feel like that was more just how i'm
wired and i dealt with it by like my
mom's a therapist like we would talk a
lot like i
my family like my dad is like you know
businessman but super emotional
like he cries all the time from
happiness and sadness and like me my
brother talks so much we all like we all
get along really well and there was
there was years when we we weren't just
because like you know every family
obviously you have moments of like you
don't understand me i'm trying to be my
own person like uh mainly i did that
but my dad didn't say that
but but i feel like i was i always felt
loved and like all the kind of chaos
that i sort of that was just like me
creating chaos as like an annoying
teenager i didn't like
it wasn't and it was never
i would always balance at the edge right
i never really went over the edge and so
i feel like i
i could still have all these like
extreme emotions and do stupid things
and be like
you know be messy which is you know not
the good word for it but like i could
still do all that and still have had an
amazing family like i just don't it
doesn't have to be
related and i understand the sort of
pressure that people that artists feel
sometimes to be like
well you need to have a reason to be the
way you are because you're not like
you're not okay or whatever the the sort
of idea is that you're not okay you just
like comedians i was like comedians are
crazy it's like no we
we just advertise our thought what
everybody else thinks you guys you know
what's crazier sitting around thinking
it and making no money off of it and not
telling anyone that to me is crazy that
you're just living with these feelings
and not alchemizing them where it's like
so to me yeah i think the sanest thing
you can do is say exactly just let it
out but i also wonder
i feel like also now that we live we all
live in such close proximity to people
that we don't know and we're always kind
of meant to sort of make ourselves
smaller to not annoy the people around
to like make sure that we can coexist
without it being so
like being uncomfortable for anyone and
that kind of
in the end goes so far that you're not
allowed to ever express how you feel in
the moment because that will like
of course you don't want to unleash on
someone you don't know but i think if
you at least did that with the people
close to you and you're like i'm not
saying you did anything wrong but i feel
this way today and that's just how it is
so i cannot be so scared of strong
emotions they're not unleashing on
people you uh don't know that means
you're not flying a commercial
i just learned something about you
we were probably just laughing
hilariously tov and i whatever because
we're just buddies so i thought a great
transition into talking about our
sponsors would just be like
you know what i mean i actually look for
laughs when i transition so it's good if
you just do them by
yourself so as you can tell this is an
ad for better help
based on the last 30 seconds of us
talking i feel like we should just send
this to our better health counselors
just go hey what are you making this
um
i've been grappling with an issue lately
one issue that's generous many a litany
of issues and
when i go to my therapist i
i never know where to start and i feel
like i want to do a session with my
better health therapist that's just
questions that like i don't know if i
should ask this
i don't know if this is important but i
feel like it's worth bringing up okay
you want to run them by us yeah like
little things that are just i don't know
if they're weird just weird quirks or
they probably are if they're like
something i need to talk through with a
professional they also probably are that
like
is it am i the only person that when i
get anxious i well what i do is i dig
out ingrown toenails whether they're
there or not
and
i dig them out i can't stop i do it
obsessively
to the point of when my to where my toes
are bleeding and then i'm sore
the next day when i walk around so
translation does anyone else mutilate
themselves i'm just saying but toes
don't count because they're so gross
right right i know right is it
incarnation if it's making everyone
else's life better because they don't
have to look at your e-t-toes but it's
also my toes are weird and like
bleedy is that something that to talk to
i want to ask about your phantom
toenails yes okay because you know it it
does make me feel better it's a weird
like i should just drink like an adult
no do what makes you happy dig your
toenails what about the fact that i'm
why we're not therapists do it uh emily
do you have any things that you
like are sort of not sure you should
bring up your therapist i'm wondering if
i should talk to my counselor about
whether or not i can track down a woman
who went into a public stall in a
restroom that i just used all i did was
pee and i flushed
i left she walked right in turned right
around on a heel and left yeah you
farted no i didn't so i found her on
instagram and i was wondering oh god
and i want to know why she did that
what did i do in there maybe it was this
aura that she got a whole photo probably
yeah she was like what the fuck about
the fight
it wasn't yeah it wasn't about smells
about energy the biggest burn you can do
to another human being you know what
you're right i am like embarrassed by
proxy maybe she forgot something maybe
she was like my tampon i forgot on a
dime open the door and i was
when the establishment an airport
huh yeah
she uh-huh did she have luggage
she had a roller bag maybe she finally
she backed up the rollerblade maybe she
went in there and farted and that's all
she needs to do you know you didn't like
queef dude i did not quite
because i when i when i pressed the
button and
wiped and put the paper down i was like
this is a good solder i'm leaving this
in a good place
that you give yourself a score when you
leave a public restroom you're like got
it yes so i should bring it up oh yeah
okay yes yes for sure okay sorry sure
mentioned i think mine are a little more
normal like i live alone every time i go
to the kitchen i go hello everyone
um just because you know i don't know if
they have feelings with all that
groceries i just want to greet them i
just want you know i don't know how
something going to feel so i just want
to make sure that i'm entering the space
politely so every time i go into the my
bathroom or like my little extra room or
whatever i'm like
i don't know what it is you greet your
products
i just wanted to go hello everyone
you're more positive when you walk in
to talk to her you get up two or three
times not to go in the kitchen and see
if you have any more cheer left
i also slept should we start putting
some groceries around the office so the
benton greets us with a warm morning
greeting
i don't think he's ever said hello to me
when he's never
we might get stuck in this house forever
better help is an online counseling
service that is more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available it's
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp and good for
your listeners get 10 off their first
month at betterhelp.com
i spend a lot of time talking to my
therapist
about how stressed out i am about money
because i have a lot of student loans
that's what you're stressed out about of
all the things in your life well for
this for this ad yes i'm sorry she said
stress out i am
well let's okay yeah let's go back we
should that was a lovely intro i
couldn't help myself emily do you spend
a lot of time
talking about
i spend a lot of time talking to my
therapist about how stressed i am
it's not weird that i knew you were
gonna say that it's like we just fill in
each other's we're best friends
sentences yeah
sandwiches and we didn't meet in college
we did not nothing nothing good comes
from college you know what i was making
no good decisions in college so i
probably would have i would have ignored
you not one oh
you'd be jealous
so you would have been real jealous i'm
jealous right now i'm good
i'm always jealous
okay we're not the better hell bad
anymore we are talking about earnest
i just feel like i've been around here
for a second okay college loans are
insane because of the age at which you
are consenting you have no idea what
you're signing up for right right no 18
year old should be expected to make that
kind of decision about that kind of
amount of money absolutely at that age
right you know like of course we thought
it was a good idea to sign up for the
200 000 loan we thought we were gonna be
you know melanie griffin in working girl
and just walk in and just get a job
willy-nilly right we had no idea okay we
i had a lot of bad ideas when i was 18.
going to college with the without the
money to pay for it i also dated guys
with chain wallets
i also thought a 401k was a marathon
i also thought clear bra straps were
clear that's not the mindset
of a person that can make decisions
about their future financial future yeah
it's insane i when i when i was in
college i thought i was going to get my
ears purchased at claire's
in the mall i was 23 years old you were
not at it and then to celebrate i went
to panda express sure i shouldn't be
allowed two hundred thousand dollars
but before they give you student loans
they should ask have you eaten at panda
express in the last four years yeah and
if you answer yes they're like here's 15
to cover that
stop
so we're just talking about all the bad
ideas we had when we were 18. when i was
18 i was so misinformed i thought sperm
was green because boogers are green and
both of those things come out of your
body
yours was the worst for sure that's the
worst one
i thought you were going to say
something about dr seuss
i figured that's for more green because
green and things are green
anyway i shouldn't have been allowed to
make any decisions about money no if you
don't even know what color your jizz is
your idea is yes
you should have been allowed to leave
the house let alone borrow money but the
rest of us thank god for earnest with
today's low interest rates it's a great
time to refinance your student loans
earnest offers low rate student loan
refinancing and you can check your rate
risk free in just two minutes with
earnest you get radically flexible
payments and you can pick your loan
terms ernest is offering our listeners a
hundred dollar cash
bonus refinance your student debt at
earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions apply now
ernest is giving our listeners a 100
cash bonus that's right now refinance
your student loans at earnest.com
whitney terms and conditions
they do apply
once again you're going to get a 100
cash bonus when you visit earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply listen up get the shit
out of your ears
visit earnest.com whitney for more
details terms and conditions
apply earnest student loan refinancing
made by earnest operations llc nmls
number one two oh four nine one seven
california financing law license number
six oh five four seven eight
eight five three five mission street san
francisco california 94105 visit
earnest.com
licenses for a full list of licenses if
you're that kind of person you're going
to figure this out
i still struggle with the frustration
that people can come from something
stable and still be
wildly creative and brilliant uh
in a way that i think i used to go like
oh something awful must have happened to
you so you know you disassociated and
thought the
um
uh disco tits video is so
bananas
in the best way it is such a haunted
house of delightful horrors and bizarre
oddities like it is so
like i'm like there's no way this came
from a happy home like
in the best way
and it's given me all this um
inspiration because i feel like so much
of what i've done has been from like all
this dark stuff happened to me and i'm
going to talk about it that's all and i
worry that if dark stuff stops happening
or if i stop being in pain or stop you
know subscribing to that story or if i
don't go oh no actually
you know everything that happened to me
was the um was for the best whatever
that i'm not going to be able to be
creative like that
and
you you're really debunking some of my
old stories that that keep me stuck and
i'm
annoyed and grateful
um because all my excuses are out how
does something like that
how do you know
because if anyone pitched me the idea
i'd be like that's silly if that's gonna
be cute for like five minutes it's gonna
be too weird like i
can see it doesn't you know when you see
something on the rack that sucks and but
on it's cute like that to me is like
that video was a horrible idea until it
was done and it was the best video i
think i've seen in 10 15 minutes oh
thank you
uh i i feel like uh i mean i love that
video so i love that you you oh
everything you said about is exactly
what i wanted it to be i think i've just
always been
i maybe have like because i think about
like my childhood and i was like you
know
mainly a happy kid but i also was like
quite sad at times i think i was just
like naturally because of being a
creative before i realized i was a
creative kid you just want to be in your
feelings
i think you just like if you're creative
there's like
there's just more of that um
and so
i not only if you're creative but i
think a lot of creators have that like
you know um you just like where your
hardness leave and you're yours and your
emotions are always there and they like
and so i remember i mean i would do i
would be very fascinated with darkness
i'd be fascinated with like
you know like murder i would like you
know commit like murder on my dolls like
put knives in them and hide them and
then i'll be the detective to find them
and stuff like that and we're gonna
we're gonna back up
we're gonna slow down uh we're gonna
rewind so commit murder on the doll yes
how
did that go i would like steal a knife
from the kitchen and stab the doll like
put the knife into the doll was it like
a like a baby baby okay
i'm realizing how bad this
my detective uh alter ego which was
bianca
glitter rose okay um and she was a very
fancy
detective i fancied
just wear like a princess dress and some
rainbow shoelaces and then she would you
know she would run around to get
so that would be like how and i would
love to play by myself i'd be annoyed if
my friends wanted to play with me i'm
like oh now they're going to try and get
into my fantasy world and i just make
all the rules there now they're going to
tell my mom about this troubling
behavior and now i'm going to get
removed from school and have to see the
therapy lady
yeah so a lot of
i don't know i guess i i just like
always had that like in me a little bit
and um and so i think just like i've
always just like to push the boundaries
you know and kind of um kind of give in
to like those
my imagination just kind of goes wild
and then i was working with um tamara
this director throughout fire fade and
fairy dust and also the disco this video
i think was the last thing that we did
together
and
he was like very willing to like go
there with me and almost like even more
i almost had to hold him back sometimes
i'm like
we're not we're not doing that
i'll tell you something about this video
there was a they had made like on the
little puppet they've made like a dick
and he was like what why don't you just
like hold the dick and i'm like
no
that's the limit i'm drawing the line
right here he's like you look so weird
i'm like yeah we got enough weird it's
enough weird happening now there's just
no coming back from no there's nothing
what if i like it
what if i like and then
i'm at i'm at furry parties
i'm like getting kicked out of the
american girl doll store like i can't
i just can't that's
you also have to remember that like with
the puppet there was like
one to four people controlling the limbs
so there was like people in body socks
always around
controlling this puppet so it was kind
of like this awkward like
do we also have to have a connection
like am i only it was so like it was the
most
with a puppet not a foursome with men
and socks i wasn't prepared i would have
dressed completely differently it was
just like you know it was just so it was
the most bizarre video i've ever done
and i think when we were done with that
we're like
i think that's all that i think that's
like we should we should you know go
different paths now because this is
getting sick
that was gonna be fun like you and i are
bad for each other we were like we were
like definitely on good terms and like
he's incredibly talented but it was just
like a moment of like
yep that that's it that's the end candy
you're fired yeah we're fired let's fire
each other we are toxic for each other
no i think he even said he's like i feel
like we did what we could do i'm like i
agree i feel like this has run its core
yes
but i'm fascinated because it makes
total sense that you're um uh we'll talk
about the movie that you just did the
immigrants yeah e-m-i-g
your natural um
sort of ability to perform and be an
actress like you know is that something
that came natural to you because to me
as someone that i put myself out there a
lot people say like it's a stand-up like
i could never do that i love your
stand-up thank you i agree thanks so
funny thank you um but uh thank you i'm
gonna receive that and that always makes
me awkward um
the same times with whitneycomings.com
and so
i in watching i have to be honest with
you like watching the video the you and
nick jonas video the cl like it makes me
uncomfortable because the connection
feels so real
and
is it
to the point of
being like is this acting but you're
giving me the exact experience i want
which is like in this moment i
completely believe it like are you able
to kind of go in and just go
like obviously
the most beautiful people in the world
it makes sense that they have chemistry
but are you able to go in and just knock
it out and then just drop it we were
just like we did the jingle ball tour
together and we kind of became friends
so i feel like and like he's an actor i
feel like i mean i wasn't acting then
but i always felt like it was something
i love to do and i love to act on my
videos so i would say like
i don't know also when you're shooting
that kind of stuff there's not really
there's not really time for the two of
us to like have a moment because there's
like guys in in this one green screen
socks running around
sexy environment which is why as someone
like i know what it takes to make a
music video a tv show there's no way to
catch that kind of performance like you
know it feels so smooth and it feels
like it's actually happening in front of
you but it's like stop down wait we need
that she got a hair and like there's
nothing sexy about it but i feel like we
we really like um we were just both like
in the zone like let's let's nail how
this looks but i definitely feel like
you're you're so
focused on
all the little things going around that
you don't really have a moment i don't
know i haven't done like um maybe if you
do a longer
movie where there's like i don't really
have in the immigrants i don't really
have any like
uh
love scenes or like kind of like that
but i don't know maybe if you shoot a
movie for months and all it is about is
your chemistry i i bet it's probably
hard to
just let it go after turn it off yeah i
don't know i guess that's why so many
actors end up together after shooting
together yeah uh they're monsters yeah
just because they're monsters
boundaryless monsters yeah
that's probably why yeah selfish yeah
but but i do think that i feel like i'm
pretty good at turning it on and off
like i can
see that like this is a moment but it's
not my life you know
yeah yeah i mean that's in and just
the i mean i i i just
it's very rare that i get like
uncomfortable
do you know what i mean it's like the
perfect kind of handle most things but
yeah it's very rare that i'm like oh
awkward i would have a hard time as your
person being okay with that like your
your husband is he
where does he stand on all those he's
fine i mean we obviously shot that
before
me and charlie even even uh met but it
was still like you know
we were
it was we were we were friends it wasn't
that you know but it was obviously we
were still able to create this chemistry
and we knew that it looked hot it was
like yeah we nailed that you know but it
was very much like a
yeah man
yeah like bro trust me i know a lot of
my best friend platonic friends that are
like brothers to me are comedians that
people find very sexy and i like can't
i'm like like it would feel like incest
to me but there's just yeah and i think
like i think just because
um
yeah i don't know it just but also maybe
because i was maybe i didn't even have
time to think about it because i was
honestly also very nervous because like
he's a huge artist and has been famous
his whole life and i was like i'm
featuring on his song and like we're
doing this i'm doing a dance routine for
the first time ever really kind of in a
yeah
in a video so that was so technical yeah
and i was very just nervous to make sure
i nailed it like um yeah
but it was cool it was a really cool
experience it was a good challenge i
don't think and i was talking to grace
about it because i don't know what it's
you know like when i was younger music
videos
were i mean our life it's how we worked
everything out it's how we like we're
able to put
words and experience how we learned how
to kiss like it's how we learned how to
be
cry in the rain like everything was just
so emo like you felt everything through
that yeah i think what kids now kind of
get through chat rooms or reddit or the
internet or i don't know but music
videos were everything and i think
artists now kind of are like
the music you
make you care so much
music videos like the ones i used to
watch that have like a beginning in the
middle and end and you give a shit and
you care and it's um like a little mini
movie that
that not only do you get to have your
own experience with a song then you get
to have this other experience with the
song where it's like oh i didn't see it
that way like you know and you get to
have just this range of emotions um
that is it is it is such an intimate
experience but but
i i don't know i just it really
felt
like what porn's supposed to feel like
you know what i am i'm the person that
goes to a strip club and it's like the
stripper likes me
like i watch that video and i'm like
look at this you can't fake that you're
like it's called acting dumbass like
it's like when i see you know your
friends like the bottle service girl
like the guy's like i think i'm going
home with her tonight i'm like sure you
are just buy another bottle
she keeps coming back to the table over
and over again she
but i do because i just think about how
sensitive you are and i'm like oh my god
the person that has made these such raw
heart-wrenching you know songs that pull
on our heartstrings so deeply and give
us goosebumps like the same person that
that has to go in and do these like
super emotional scenes i found myself
being like was she okay
yeah did she go to her car and go like
we can't play together no no no no no no
no
no i feel like it's like business like
you can kind of shut it off i think i
can when it comes to a performance like
i think maybe because i relate to it as
a performance it's more when i like when
i
uh write a song when i sing i think then
that is the more like emotional toll for
me
but when i when i'm performing
like a video i don't know maybe it's
because i feel like i'm i'm acting and
telling a story that i'm like not
thinking about it as my story as much
that makes sense and i think that when
it comes like sexual like kind of
chemistry moments like
um
i don't know it's just kind of if i'm in
love with someone else then
that i can still i mean obviously i can
find another person attracted but that's
a hot person yeah but i am very like
i'm as much i can appreciate another
person's hotness i'm still very much my
attraction and my like the person i want
is the person i'm in love with yeah so
and i think i don't know why i mean i
guess charlie like he could he could
have been way more jealous and not okay
with it like um but he just is okay with
it he just also knows who he started you
know he went to the premiere of fairy
dust
like where i'm the of the end credit is
me masturbating like crazy for all of
them and granny panties yes
it took a long time for you to reach
climax
i'm not going to blame the granny
panties but
it was like a little bit more hang on
yeah
we just need one more i need one more
camera i need to finish i need more
cameras there's not enough cameras in my
face for me to climax but it's like but
he you know he he saw that that's so he
knows what he got himself into kind of
thing yeah but he's very chill with it
all he just like and he he was like him
he's like used to model he was a child
actress in new zealand so like he kind
of gets it a bit you know yeah um
so i think he he just like isn't yeah
and also like we we work together like
we he does creative with me as well like
um uh the visual stuff so he's very
involved in the videos so he's like very
on board with like whatever the song
needs that's what we'll do you know and
how do you because there's such a
the way that you have made these shorts
fire fade and fairy dust fairy dust i do
want to just get granular about this
because i've been in lots of meetings to
make things and you have the idea of
what you want and then the rawest
coolest version then you get in there
and there's 300 people in the room and
you're like
well the scene is going to be mastered
me masturbating for four minutes
straight and then you get in the room
and you're like i give me like 20 i mean
it's not and then you go into wardrobe
and you're like what was i doing like
and then it starts to and then it starts
to get less risky and less brave and
further from your vision further from
your vision because more people get
involved and fear sets in and whatever
and then
feedback sets in yeah uh human resources
sets in in my case what how do you
maintain the integrity of because it
just does not look like you have
compromised on any moment in those
shorts or your videos
no i i think
probably because um i end up sort of
paying for them myself there you go
you're like i paid for this so i'm gonna
masturbate for four minutes and you guys
are gonna watch that you're like that's
how i joined the crew that day i was out
of money so i was like can i masturbate
in front of you yeah yeah would that be
good does that count do you like that
and maybe some pizza you can eat pizza
can we just watch you have sex with a
puppet and that'd be fine we won't
charge you no but that honestly have
been the thing and but i also will give
credit to my label for kind of because
you know they could have easily been
like we're not putting this out this is
not coming out you know that's like when
you sign to a label that's kind of the
the what you're giving up it's like
we're now collaborating on my
thing you know yeah and but they've
always been really cool and like we
don't really get this but
you can do it we just won't
finance all of it you know which like
and they still did like i mean we'll
watch it over and over and over and over
and over but we will never work with
them exactly though but i feel like they
they did like um
everything they could as a major label
to
support something like that you know
because it's pretty out there it's
pretty dark it's very sexual like it's
it's it's hard i think also
here like in the states where there's a
lot of judgment on that a lot of the
time um especially mixing
sexual moments that aren't maybe
necessarily very hot do you know what i
mean like i kind of like yeah and i kind
of like doing something it's like you
expect me to be
acting sexy but instead i'm just
doing sexual things and then like i can
i know that like bothers a lot of men a
lot of times like why do you have to do
it like that like it's not even hot i'm
like it's not about me being hot for you
in this moment it's about like a rawness
and like me and my own zone
but it is hot which is why they're
dming you to say it's not
like
but there is such a um
it reminds me actually this is the
highest compliment i can give anyone is
gaspar noes movie irreversible which i
talk about a lot
yes on this
because it really does change the way
you're you see the world it was like the
most um
mundane moments it's a it's a movie that
is told in reverse with i believe only
three takes with monica bellucci and
vincent cassell and it's known for its
uh it's been called um
unwatchable yeah um because there is
such a brutal
rape scene in it but
once you see it because it's told in
reverse and once you uh see the brutal
things that happened that night and then
you see them just in bed snuggling
having a stupid fight at a party
everything all of a sudden feels so
stupid in every moment that would be
mundane if it was playing in real time
the correct way would be boring but now
all of a sudden it's like every moment
is a missed opportunity and everything
is so precious all of a sudden and you
do this
what he does which is like you don't let
people look away from sort of the
more the only word i can think of is
like mundane
uh moments thank you but that's what's
so hot about it because it's like oh
that's how it really happened to me it's
so unattractive to see something like
you know porn or something that's cut
together and she's faking an orgasm she
has an orgasm in 20 seconds you're like
in what world
has a dick ever done that to someone
you know so
what is that why what is that tattoo and
it's not for her you know it's not her
moment but it just feels false it feels
like artifice yeah you know and i think
that sex is so different for everybody
and that's what's so cool about it but
when you look at porn you're like i
guess everyone just has sex the same
weird way or masturbates the same way
and then you see what you do
and there's this permission to be
um
different isn't uh a good interesting
enough word but
um specific and like a weirdo all of a
sudden it's like it's cool it's like
bizarre
bizarre sexy but it's also there's that
but but but also but um
also just so uh your instinct to just be
surprising like at all costs like
whatever it is so if if a porn is you
know if they're gonna show a fake orgasm
in 20 seconds you're gonna do four
minutes of just like
i'm
it's fascinating like i um i've talked
about this before but i love that thing
there's this but it's just sort of like
you expect me to get this done faster
you expect me to be in the song you
expect me it's just a way to deconstruct
all the ways that we a way to unlearn
all of the stereotypes that we've
learned and all of the expectations that
we've been brainwashed with and there's
such a uh it's just so cool and i'm
trying to not use the word gritty
because it has a negative connotation
because to me everything else is just
saccharine and fake what you're doing is
just
so real in a way that makes other people
go like oh i'm not a weirdo i'm not you
know what i mean yeah i see what you
mean yeah you know it makes me really
happy in the best way i love being a
weirdo but you're not but that's the
whole point you're not
the people that have orgasms in 20
seconds or weirdos how do you move
through the world there's no way how do
you get on planes with turbulence how do
you ride horses how do you wear glasses
all the time how do you wear tight jeans
it would just be like you sit down and
you get one a nightmare yeah exactly how
do you move through the world what are
you doing during an earthquake you're
just like having an orgasm during an
earthquake like how do you function in
the world
um i want to ask you um
as someone that has expressed so uh uh
sort of the
um
ridiculously addictive
uh
uh magnetic pull
to someone that's maybe bad for us or
some a situation that's maybe dangerous
or as people that tend to do the same
thing over and over again and expect a
different result or going to get that
hit of adrenaline or shame is someone
that is is so eloquently and beautifully
explores that in their work do you
believe in soul mates do you believe in
love at first sight or are those toxic
notions
um
i feel like
i guess to me like love
doesn't necessarily mean that it's
your lifetime love do you know what i
mean so i feel like and i do think that
you can find a soulmate but i don't
necessarily think that there's only one
you know so i i think that
when you sort of fall for someone
instantly i would say that's more
passion and lust
fascination driven there's like that
sort of mystery there but infatuation
yeah but i don't think you can call it
love until you've seen a whole person
and like like oh you do this oh i'm not
sure i like that about you but i still
love you like i still want to
um
be with you and then i feel like
there's so many different ways that
love can be but for me now that i'm like
okay this is this is real love this is
the real shit with charlie and i think
for me the feeling is i never want to
ever do anything
to hurt him or disrespect him i never
feel the need to have like the power in
the relationship or there's never like a
oh he did that so i'm gonna do this like
no it's just like vulnerable and honest
and i still get jealous sometimes i
still have moments of like do you even
love me you know i think but
yeah but but i feel
but i still but what i know is like i
always want to make him happy and i
think that is like love to me like i
just really respect him and i feel
really respected back respect is my
number one thing i think that's the
number one thing it's not only the
hottest thing
but it's also um
the thing that makes us not want to act
out in those childish ways of like i
want to test you i want to play this
game with you because i've done all that
in my life like i've been
a shitty person in relationships i've
been treated badly like just i've done
it all yeah
thank god as you should
yeah so that when the right when charlie
does come along you actually can
appreciate it you're like oh
you're being good to me that's great
yeah like wait a second
um but that's that's really fascinating
to me because um you know i just grapple
with this uh uh sort of what love means
and whether it should be what people
always say like relationships take work
i really
vacillate back and forth on that but i
remember um
in my not last special especially before
i did a thing no three three ago i did
this um did a joke about love where
uh i said um i think the definition of
love is
being willing to die for someone that
you yourself want to kill
yeah i mean like if a burglar came into
the house with a gun to kill you'd be
like stop yeah let me do it can i do it
since you're here or can i just do it
like if this is going to go down anyway
i think it's that it's like that
tolerance of the things that
that on someone else you would think was
annoying or frustrated it's just me
everything's just worth it yeah and
you're not even consciously having to go
like you're choosing your battles in a
way that's unconscious you're like
that's not even worth it i don't even
want to spend waste his time exactly and
kind of like i know i know it's not
coming from a bad place so that's not
you know it's it's kind of like a
you just know you want to keep it
good so you're not like
i guess it's just like you don't i don't
question it and i never think about it
being work i'm never like
oh it's supposed to be hard work can't
always be easy i never feel like
if things if we're having like a moment
where it's like
doesn't feel great then it's like
usually it's like outside circumstances
rarely between us it's like something in
the vicinity of us so like the world or
work or whatever it's usually not
between him and me where it's like
something is is bad that's going on
but
i do and i do think it also helps us
that like we do spend some time apart
we're like obviously we've been together
a lot now which has been amazing but we
have no problem with being away from
each other for a few weeks at a time or
like a month at a time
and
that also you know trust obviously plays
you know but i think that also it's like
important to be your own people even if
you love to be together to like not be
nervous about being doing things
separately like that also is a huge um
and that i think is way more common in
sweden than here yeah like for example
a small thing but like when you go to
weddings like big birthday parties or
something in sweden and you do like um
uh like planned seating you never sit
with your date or your person you come
with so you're just like
everyone's spread out
a prank let's make sure we're happy
let's make our friends cheat on each
other
no that's what i mean you don't like
assume that that's gonna happen you
don't think of men and women being
friends as like they're gonna cheat
together can i tell you
i dated a couple english guys it is
europe in general
guys just have friends that are all
girls
and you're like what are you doing like
and my brain is like well you have to be
having sex with them and
and it's my sexism because they're like
why do you think i've never thought that
ever like i have so many more guy
friends than like well you must be
sleeping with her and she's like well
then you're implying that she's nothing
but a physical object you're the one
that's sexist i think she's interesting
and cool and i'm like impossible
yeah
she's hot too you can't be friends with
a hot girl yes you must be having sex
with her all the time or want to have
sex with like it doesn't compute to me
that a guy would want to have a platonic
relationship with a beautiful woman well
i think that's and that's i think is
maybe
more common here but i would i never had
that thought like of course you can tell
you did everyone's goals
no but i never have that like um
like
charlie has a lot of girlfriends and
like i'm really close friends with them
now too so it's just and the same with
my my my male friends they're just all
yeah i think i think he
we're just i mean he's from new zealand
maybe it's similar over there too but we
both were like kind of we're talking
about with our american friends they're
like i think it's more
rare here in general that that's like
it's it's less common to be
um kind of a mixed group of friends or
when you're in a couple at least you
kind of
sort of swing
or like you kind of lose touch with your
friends from up from a different
gender i think that's changing though
with like you know over like
the younger donation i think it's way
more just a mix of everyone's friends
with everybody right right right we
don't see gender yeah yeah and that's
fascinating to me because i i've been
reluctant to bring this up but i i think
i'm taking a page uh out of your book
and i'm gonna be fearless about what
i've been thinking which is
i think about how
um brilliantly you convey and and create
this catharsis around our like deepest
carnal desires taking away the judgment
it doesn't matter like if what
christians think would you what what
anything socially constructed is i feel
jealous i feel heartbroken i'm addicted
to this person even though they're bad
for me like i want to do all these other
things to self-suit like all there's no
judgment on it right
but as asking for a friend um in terms
of being married do you ever worry about
you know i don't
i used to worry about the other person i
don't trust you you're gonna cheat on me
because that was my low self-worth that
was me i i had low self-esteem in terms
of the person i picked the person i
thought i deserved and then myself why
would anyone want to be faithful to me
i'm garbage right i don't have that
anymore my thing now is if you cheat on
me
godspeed
like i enjoy feels so bad for like you
have to go through life being the person
that cheated on me like pathetic you're
basically the guy that cheated on halle
berry like i am now at a place where i
understand how self-destructive it would
be for you to do that
but um i sometimes worry about just
because i have a unconditionally
accepting relationship with human nature
and our carnal instincts and i am at a
point where i can see attractive people
and go like and be okay with someone i'm
in love with seeing attractive people
and not feeling like it's a threat
do you ever worry about your own like
the beast inside us that is like
constantly searching for dopamine and
searching for oxytocin and a thrill and
adrenaline
um
i don't not not yet like i'll i'll be
like i think we talk about this so much
too like we will check out hot people
together and it's not and i think even
like the fact that we can talk about
definitely
whitney coming towards her yeah totally
i'm like what are you doing what do you
think
i'm like you're not coming
no but i feel like um i we talk about it
a lot in terms of like
if you ever felt like you wanted to be
with someone else just tell me first
kind of thing like we can talk about it
kind of openly without being so
scared of maybe that happening sometime
in the future i don't know like i guess
it's like a um
i just accepted that
maybe one day i'll feel
nervous about that but but i i you know
hope that i am
10 15 years like still like right now i
feel like in 10 15 years i still will
not think that that's worth it you know
and what you're saying what i love that
you're saying and i just is that like
also because
you know i feel like i've gotten all
that out of my system that's a very
sophisticated way of saying i was a
whore
i mean i was a whore too yeah but so
yeah it was just you know
the best way thank god because now i
have no instinct to cheat i know how
that ends i know what that is like yeah
and i think we're stumbling upon kind of
what love means which is sort of the
that is not worth hurting you for one
second yeah whatever that is whatever my
neurochemicals want whatever my ovaries
are saying like procreate with that
person or that person has tattoos like
marry him or you know whatever like um
he is a malignant narcissist procreate
with him like all those i have such a
um
sort of um friendly relationship with my
shadow and my sort of the deepest
darkest thoughts which i'm able to go
like that's just human nature that's
just my body that's just like the
species trying to procreate that's just
my brain trying to trick me into
procreating with someone that's tall
that's all that is and i think that's
what like is cool i think once you can
actually
talk to each other about like and also
like check other people out together
without that having to be
a threat you know like every just
because another person's hot doesn't
mean that that makes you any less hot
like it's just kind of that
doesn't mean that the person that you
are with is like oh why am i with you i
really wish i was with that random
person walking by me right now like that
maybe
and i love that you're saying this
because i realized i used to think the
dream is a guy who's in love with me and
thinks every other woman is heinous and
then you just know how it works why
would you want that no i want you to
think that woman's beautiful and now
she's gorgeous you don't think she's
gorgeous oh you're a shallow asshole i
want you to think every woman is
gorgeous maybe for different reasons but
i realize like oh in my jealousy
and my need to be the only one because
i'm so afraid of being abandoned because
i have such low self-worth that i think
that i'm you know that sane people would
would
sort of trash this that would be more
reflection on their own limitations you
know than mine but the idea that i'm
like i don't want him to think any women
are stunning i want him to think all
these because all these women are
stunning yeah you don't think so that is
the other fight oh you know she's pretty
what do you mean she's pretty she's
gorgeous so you don't think i'm pretty
okay so yeah it's just the whole thing
like i'm the only person i think is
pretty that's shallow i mean
but i think but i think that's the
the the
key to it for me is really just like not
not being
like enjoying other hot people
with him or like you know checking them
out together and it's like oh look how
hot she's like oh yeah she's really hot
or like look at his abs like oh his abs
are great we don't want to marry that
guy don't want to destroy this over the
guy with the chain wallet no we can say
that for a second you know yeah sort of
like i'm so picturing this guy with the
tattoos in the chain wallet and
everything just like when i was 25 that
would have been a i would have given him
six months of my life yeah but i also
think that like i i also had such i
think because myself i i used to cheat i
used to have you know untoward thoughts
i used to do shady things so i would
project onto other people i would assume
everybody else was as sneaky as i was or
as um you know surreptitious as i was
and it took me a while because i used to
get very jealous of guys watching porn
and you know now i'm like
great
like yeah
go learn some new moves that benefits me
you know i want something with a bit
more of a story yeah i can do that
i am a filmmaker i would just like the
the cinematographers
enough but stop buying it
i do think she's crying and not supposed
to be i feel like i've never really had
a problem with
um
boyfriends watching porn or whatever but
but i think i
uh i can i quite like porn sometimes but
there's definitely like a limit where
i'm like well this just isn't for me
like i'm not like this is not like i'm
not feeling this is a sexy moment no
well some porn is amazing so like you
know there's some porn well porn there's
just so much of it there's so much of it
and there's this new trend where
there's like funny porn that i hate i
hate that i love that i
hate that shit where it's like someone
walks in on someone else and it's like
it's like the three stooges they're like
oh my god and you're like dude this bad
acting is drying up my pussy in a way
that is like shocking
it's like but i just i kind of watch
that just because it's funny you know
because it's like it's not turning me on
but like watching you know that like
blow up t-rex costume that you can get
there's like porn with that when there's
a girl on a hoverboard getting chased by
that and then he's like
wow and then he like bangs her in this
outfit and it's so funny but i can't
it's not sexy at all it's just hilarious
but there's something nice about that
because you're not distracted by
the goatee or like he's so much older
than her or like no exactly what's that
tattoo it says mom like it's because to
me i find i i get distracted very easily
and if i start to worry about anyone
worry about the goatee or when i start
looking at the background of like that's
an ikea bed it looks like it's gonna
break i've been through this like you
got you know um but yeah there's
something nice about
it being um oddly inhuman or at least
under a disguise in a way yeah i think
that's like
why also maybe why it's like
also you know i think you know the girls
are usually just way more beautiful than
the guys
just like in general so
if if a guy is just really turning me
off even if the girl's turning me on i
have a hard time getting into it because
i'm just like you're not because you're
like not made for her this is not fair
no it gets very frustrating sometimes um
but i think for me it also took me a
while to have enough respect for either
the person i'm with or just men in
general to go just because you're
watching this for 20 minutes whatever
that's generous um just because you're
watching this doesn't mean you're like
she's the love of my life like i want
her like there's not yeah that's not
what's happening no no dude i'm saying
yeah i you barely fell in love with me
it took me a year and a half to get you
to realize how amazing i am you're not
going to fall in love with her after 30
seconds of her bad acting so it took me
so long to not be threatened by that um
and then i also want to ask you because
watching your videos and listening to
your music i have this
this frustration that's like how does
she know when she's done with a song
because this is such an eternal
uh
sort of human nate there's so much to
say on this like do you ever how do you
know it's pencils down
it's um it's definitely
you can i feel like you can work on a
song forever especially when it comes to
like the production and sort of like the
little details like you can you can like
tweak it for forever
but there is a feeling of like i think
especially with um
with the the lyrics where i just like
because you know there's so much that
needs to to connect like the lyrics need
to be
the best possible version of the melody
together and like it has to all be
work so perfectly as as one body of work
so
i think once you feel like oh i got to
say i mean it's really hard to like you
said like have tell this story that's
massive in like you know three minutes
or like in in one sentence you explain
this huge feeling that people all share
right right
so it's hard to to know but i feel like
once i'm on a roll with
what i want to say i kind of picture a
scenario play out
in my head like the story i want to tell
and so then
and it can be like a quick moment or
it's like you know
a lifetime thing or just like a thought
but once i have that once i can see it
in my head
then i know i can kind of finish it to
where it's like okay this is where the
story ends kind of thing this is where
the scenario ends
and
usually i can't
if i don't have the
lyrical sort of the concept or the
storyline or like the the emotion i want
to write about i have a really hard time
just like
finishing the song like that needs to
kind of be there for me to even come up
with melodies i need to have like a this
is what i want to say
so
i'm starting in that end now i know the
tone of the song and so we can build
around that but just like kind of
sometimes you know i just improvise
melodies over a track and then i'm like
but what does it mean though like i
don't even know what these melodies mean
because they have to be connected to
lyrics for me and that a lot of people
work very differently to that but i
i really need the connection between the
two to really be able to feel like it's
gonna be
something that means something to me
yeah i know if that answers your
question it doesn't answer my question
because there's times where
you'll have such a um
a lyric that is so is such a labyrinth
and is so like
i know
what you mean now that i feel you
singing it and i see what you're doing
but
if i just saw it on a piece of paper i
would like my brain maybe it's because
i'm a community i'm like i need to
explain this more they're not gonna get
this it's too vague or it's too opaque
but that's what's so great about it yeah
and i think that's the but it's funny
though sometimes the more personal you
get the broader it gets in a weird way
like yeah it's like people can really
like
oh i know that exact moment because
usually you're rarely alone in your
experience you know so many people
especially when it comes to love like i
think so many people have been through
everything that i've been through so
if i even when i get very personal
specific a lot of people will still be
like i know exactly that's exactly what
happened to me like yes and that's like
my favorite compliment like you put
words to my emotions that's like my
oh you know that means so much to me
when like fans come up to me and tell me
that it's just like a really special
thing because that is what i needed
music for when i was little like that's
what helped me to just like understand
that oh music is my thing
i wish some people come up to you and
they're like habits put words
i wish you would just i wish you would
just be like pull your shit together
yeah are you okay that was really strong
pull it together you wreck
can i ask you as someone that has you
know i hate calling them mistakes i hate
saying we made bad decisions you know in
our 20s early 20s like we were just like
bumper cars just like is this right is
this right like you have to try it out
yes and it should be
sorry painful and awkward and weird and
confusing and you know those are all so
important you know i think that you know
as you know we talk a lot about
addiction on this show but i think
americans specifically and then addicts
and really emotional people we believe
that we deserve to be having fun all the
time everything should be easy and fun
all the time we need contrast and i
think it's it it if anyone told me this
when i was in my 20s that would i would
have been like shut up you old lady but
you know that you don't know that's the
time to feel all the feelings and to you
know you know bump your knees on all the
coffee tables of life right and so that
was not profound but kind of also at the
same time it was and i'm curious we talk
about this on the show a lot um i always
want people to take away you know things
and to be able to pass on wisdom and i
wish it existed or
i wish people were talking about
podcasts when i was younger but what do
you find are some red flags in people of
uh romantic
friends just in general and i'll give
you a second to think about it mine vary
everything from
rude to weight staff to
yeah huge big one huge
like because sometimes people tell us
who they are and we just don't want to
listen because we're too
addicted to our version of the story or
and you like want to think the best of
them so you're like i probably didn't
mean that you know chemically addicted
to get out yeah so we have to go like oh
he was having a bad day or she was you
know owner period or whatever we have to
do to stay in the
thing but i'm just curious for the
people that are able to see red flags in
u-turn i'm not one of them but i always
like to
sort of i think
someone that always says their exes are
crazy
all their exes are crazy yet they've
done nothing wrong but they're the
common and my ex is a stalker my ex is
crazy she's a psycho well then why were
you there for four years yeah she was
such a psycho and they're like oh yeah
and the one before was even more crazy
and you're like i see a pattern in you
here
um no but i would say
for me it's like if you start to feel
bad about yourself
then there's something wrong with like
if they
if they're if they make comments or like
little just little things they say about
you or like
question you in a way that you start to
question yourself and feel bad about who
you are
like of course you can always like help
to better each other but you know
there's a level of that like all of a
sudden you start to think you're ugly
all of a sudden you don't like your
style all of a sudden you're like is my
hair actually really you know if there's
like
they start to pick away at you and
you know hide it in some little like
package of like he's trying to make you
better like you know
that i think is a red flag because that
is really just someone who is trying to
manipulate you to make you believe that
they have all the answers and you're
never
really right
and like you're totally that's like and
i've been in a relationship like that
and that was really like
i remember coming out of it and be like
what like i really started questioning
everything about myself and like
doubting every sort of
emotion
thought like action that i was just a
bad person
yeah
and i think that to me like once you
start if you are seeing someone you
start to feel
a couple months in like
just feel bad about yourself or like
things you used to like about yourself
you start to be insecure about like
that's a big red flag that's huge
because it's subtle but it's
i was hesitant to say this earlier
because it sounded like narcissistic or
selfish or something but i think what
you're hitting on is is when i think
about love i'm like stop thinking about
the other person because when we're like
i love this person he does this she does
this she's like this and she's like but
who are you
are you the best version of yourself do
you you know are you the best version of
who you are when you're with them it's
not about them it's about who you are
yeah when you're with them are you
doubting yourself do you feel inspired
do you have a pit stop are you like
putting makeup on under the table you
know are you putting makeup on when you
wake up and getting back in the bed and
like you know and are you nervous about
being yourself do you feel embarrassed
of your being yourself i think that's
shame yeah you feel ashamed or like you
know um
you did you know
or like you're not enough or like every
day you're auditioning for that person's
approval yes you should have booked the
job you got the job you shouldn't feel
like you're fighting for the job every
day exactly yeah and i think that's
something i didn't understand because i
got very confused when people say
relationships take work and i was like
oh i guess that just means every day to
work for this person's approval and you
want to be also like working on i mean i
think that sometimes because i know like
i'm obviously i think being an artist
you have to be a little bit of a
narcissist you know like want attention
and like be
kind of like
it it takes a certain kind of mind if
you want to be on stage in front of a
bunch of people who are like singing
back the words you wrote and you like
feel amazing about it you know but it's
like it's like comedians it's like we
get up in front of people
they're not going to get back yeah if
you do speak a security guard will
remove you yeah
uh everyone needs to listen to talk
about how big of a piece of shit i am
exactly so you get a piece of shit i'm
talking about you need to pay money to
watch me talk about my flaws me yeah i'm
talking about me singing about me me me
so i think that is like you have to have
some of that but but i still think like
then when you're in your like
normal life always you want to have like
equal relationships with people so
i feel like if you
so i think that like plays into it so if
you're with someone who's a bit
manipulative and try to cut you down at
first you don't want to be like no i'm
great you're like okay maybe this is
something i need to yeah pay attention
to or listen to or like you know maybe i
need to work on myself because we all do
because you're not a narcissist and you
can handle feedback which is like to me
the hardest thing i think as you get
super successful famous is to surround
yourself with people that still
keep you
on the ground or just still treat you
like you know a human being but also
build you up and make it you know so
it's a tricky balance of someone for
sure i definitely have made sure to keep
people in my life for our hard on me and
who like will just be honest and just be
like
especially when it comes to
the music and the creative and kind of
like oh also in general just assuming as
a human being yeah yeah yeah yeah kind
of make sure that you remember like
who you are and what you're about and
like not to
um get caught up in it all basically and
to not get stuck in who you were like
i'm really excited like as i like listen
to your music and watch you know i think
that as artists it's the instinct is to
go like this thing worked i'm gonna keep
doing this thing yeah no i have to
evolve you have to write and like let
like your audience will
is rooting for you to grow and i think
it's taken me a long time to learn like
oh i don't only have to talk about how
you know shitty my childhood was or how
bad men have been to me or i don't have
to only be broken for them to like me
and because i think for the longest time
i was like well that's what makes me
funny that's what makes me but the whole
point of all this is to grow to triumph
over it and when i triumph all of a
sudden it's like oh you think you're
better than us now that you've you know
i'm like no trust me i'm still a piece
of shit i still have to like get drunk
strangers to like me to feel good about
myself like we're fine but there is
something so
cool about how different each of your
albums are in terms of reflecting like
where you are at the time instead of
going like i'm going to go back to that
same well that worked in the beginning
like is that a scary i've mentioned
bathtub once
but do you ever feel like
because there is a coziness to that
dysfunctional place because you get
attention and you
so many people relate to it people
generally
are less interested and maybe this is
just in a personal thing when things are
going well
people are generally just when someone's
perfect it's not perfection isn't
interesting because it just isn't a
thing you know what i mean like so
basically when someone's just portraying
this like
polished you know
perfect shiny clean surface that is like
i've never made a mistake in my life
yeah i am this like professional
you know of course that can be
impressive but i think there needs to be
a nerve
and vulnerability there that will
like
share the human side of you and when you
don't want to show that i think that
makes it really hard for people to
really connect with uh what you're
saying and so
like i but i feel like i'm still
all of that like i still like
have many moments where like just pull
yourself together come on like even you
know like i definitely have moments
where i just go off the rails in various
ways you know yeah so i'm just that's
just who i am as a person
yeah and so that's and so i feel like i
always will put that in my music because
otherwise
like it won't make sense to me like it
won't give me anything to try and
portray something but to me this is an
art this is like i love this because
it's it's like you're like i need to
pull myself together meanwhile people in
raccoon hats are storming the capital
and they think they nailed it like they
think they just killed that task and
you're like i didn't handle that well i
probably should have been nicer over
email like the fact that we beat
ourselves up
over things that we kind of nail we're
kind of nailing it
meanwhile there's all these like
ignorant people they're like killed in
it's like dude so that's true there's
something so sort of like fascinating
about that
um yeah i also think that um
and
stop me if this is like not the right
direction but as someone i do i have
been don't want to brag don't be jealous
i have been i was diagnosed as being
addicted uh uh having love addiction so
it's something that you can go in and
out of it's essentially like you know in
my case meeting someone that was the
perfect mix of the negative qualities of
my primary caretakers the perfect
recreated my childhood circumstance
neurological cocktail perfectly the
feeling of abandon the feeling of
needing to please and needing to walk on
eggshells and constantly you know it was
an addictive relationship and that how
we define it essentially is that to
continue to do something despite
negative consequences or when something
stops being fun yet you can't remove
yourself from the situation like i drove
over there every day going like we're
gonna fight and this is miserable and i
want to get out of this but you just
like you physically just like stay you
just like something your body is just
telling you to stay you get addicted to
a person which is like like this is you
know it's like having a cigarette when
you're addicted to cigarettes like i
know this is bad for me but this is
satiating this screwed up
neurochemical normal that i have it's my
homeostasis like i'm not saying it's
good it's just i feel comfortable in
this briar patch of a nightmare and so i
i feel and and and this is me projecting
on to to habits but i think it was the
first time i was like thank god someone
is like whether you intend to do it or
not describing the addictive relate
because we can get addicted to people
yeah we can get addicted to the
neurochemicals that people cause us even
when they're hurting us it gives us
adrenaline adrenaline turns into
dopamine you know we want to we just
can't focus on anything else it's the
only thing on your obsession
and i will say that like i do think that
with with charlie sometimes like
we're so great now but if things went
bad between us it would be
hell because i am addicted
but i would be um
like because i am addicted to him you
know i can know i do know that like if
if it's like if we have a fight it's
like all i think about and he's even
like
he's so
good at fighting because he's still like
reasonable and respectful to me which
makes me even angry oh god that's the
worst when you like go to break up with
someone and they handle it so well
you're like i'm in love with you again
because of the way you handled it
um no but but he's just like he is
yeah i just you know he just is very
good at dealing with stuff um i mean
don't trust me he's he's a fucking
weirdo too like we're both you know have
our
weirdness together which is great i saw
your wedding photos yeah
been more jealous like
it was perfect it was perfect i didn't
know what i wanted the wedding dress i
never wanted to get married and i didn't
know how much i would love having a
wedding i think marriage says that
i'm just saying common denominator is
like i find the people that are like i
want to get married and putting all this
pressure on people when you're not
looking it sounds cliche or like some
stupid platitude but when you're not but
it's true
yes because you weren't focused on
getting a result out of someone no
after i froze my eggs i found myself i
realized that i was i was meeting
someone i'd be like are you a good
father like you're gonna be and it was
like that's not fair to someone you're
on a second date yeah when you're going
and being like are you my husband it's
like jesus like i wouldn't are you gonna
marry me eventually yeah what are we
doing what are we doing like if you go
in that results oriented what's your
middle name again i just you know yeah
who cares we'll give you a new one i'm
gonna i'm gonna change everything about
you anyway to make you fit who i need um
so it's like going in with that like um
uh like flip that man like we're gonna
flip that house like going in like
needing results it's so selfish and it's
so vampiric and exploitative and and i
will end up so unhappy i think because
you like you you must be so stressed
yourself or that's the
the man or the woman kind of going in
with like this is the goal and this is
what i have to reach with you and if you
don't get to where i want you if this
doesn't get to where we're supposed to
be if we don't get married the ultimatum
i just think it it just like sets this
it starts you off in such a
negative energy place where it's just
like you're always going to think like
did you really want this did you really
want this you forced it and and yes what
you chase you chase away and then when
you do force something you always
question did you just do this because i
forced you right and so um but i think
there's something so fascinating about
that because it's also you're not a
complete person you're not full yet if
you find yourself going like i need you
it should be i want you yeah not i need
you and
um yeah when you go in with this idea of
what the other person should be or start
to shapeshift to try to be what you
think the other person wants you're
starting it on a lie
and you're forcing it and then the jig
will be up at some point and that's what
i find when things get toxic when it's
like i pretended to be this person this
whole time and i'm not jealous and i'm
not gonna go through your phone and i'm
this and i'm super chill and i eat wings
and i just like whatever drink beer and
i'll like hang out with your friends and
like i go bowling and like three months
and i'm like i ain't bowling i can't do
this again and he's like
well you don't like me for who i am well
you never showed me who you are that's
your fault i mean that's my fault for
being so wildly and authentic and
presenting this like fake version of
myself that i think you'll like so i can
get this result that i don't even know
if i want it's like sometimes
it's just like an unattainable project
like turns a person that you're supposed
to share something with like
into a project and that's just really
dangerous i think and it just both of
you just end up being
unhappy with each other and feeling
tricked
yeah
yeah and so it like becomes this such a
like
it's just yeah it's just toxic and yeah
you see it a lot i think and i think
especially when someone starts to feel
like i should be in a serious
relationship by now mm-hmm and i think
that's when you can kind of start to see
that sort of
the goal starts you're like this is
where i need to be in five years and
then you kind of like aim for that and
then the person just has to come along
or not you know like yeah and i think
it's like it's like you said before like
who are you in this relationship like
kind of make sure that you check in with
yourself that you're not always trying
to
fix or
adapt or like
your focus isn't always on the other
person that you also yeah like give
yourself some time to be like
wait is this really do i really want to
go bowling no i don't like actually i
don't like balloon do you mind going
with your friends i'll meet you after
the small little things anyone can get a
strike it requires no skill
i actually am so bad at bowling it's
like the worst because unless i'm really
drunk
i don't believe something should be a
sport if the less you try the better you
are
that's what it is in bowling the harder
you try the worse your chances well if
you're just drunk and like throw it it's
like strike and you're like that's not
this shouldn't be a sport that was an
accidental victory this feels wrong what
is this hollywood and so
but i do though feel like the one thing
we the word we don't use about
relationships which lets us get off the
hook we don't have to beat ourselves up
and go i'm such a bad person i made a
mistake sometimes relationships are just
addictive yeah the drama the the the
wondering the chasing the worrying it
recreates some childhood circumstances
or like you know switches on some primal
you know uh uh um you know switch that
releases adrenaline and adrenaline turns
into dopamine and like we don't have to
be like i'm in these fucked up things
and also you could just be addicted
sometimes it just happens and yeah i
think like i think that's like the it's
so easy to give
logical reasonable advice about what
someone should do who's in a
relationship that they can't get out of
or who's like acting you know
acting in a way that's not like gonna
you know help the relationship or
whatever but when like love isn't
logical so like you can't
even how much you're trying to reason
with someone like you just it's not
you're not gonna
act the way that you even that you know
that you should because it's just not
how you're feeling so it takes so much
like practice and like you know
like you talking to yourself and like
talking to your friends or talking to a
therapist to like really kind of get
your
mind out of that downward dark spiral
where you kind of end up in the same
behavior every time yeah and
but also that it's like sometimes it's
just like you just end up there and it's
okay you can get out of it you just have
to try and by the way they didn't do
anything wrong no
someone else might be able to have a
relationship with them that's not
addictive yeah and then you know fine
but i think the combination of the
youtube that is that's it that's all it
is it's like some people can just do
cocaine once a month yeah
like they can do cocaine like a
gentleman like good for you some people
just can't like there's certain guys
where it's like if i see you once
i will ruin everything i've worked so
hard for
and we will both sort of self-destruct
in a hotel room in hermosa beach and
it will just everything i've worked so
hard for will be lost
and i will have a shitty tattoo if your
name is spelled on my back and we will
just be gone like it's not your fault
it's not my fault it's just the conflict
something with you too yeah it's just
it's an allergy yeah it's like they they
describe addiction as an allergy like oh
i have an allergy to alcohol i have an
allergy to heroin because my dopamine
receptors can't hold doping the same way
it's like so i like to say with with
girls or boy whatever who still are like
pining for that person it's like oh dude
alcoholics you want to drink every day
they just don't you know what i mean
yeah like don't be so mad at yourself
for still wanting that person you just
have to
really stay away
you know way by may the way that we were
designed was kind of to just get
pregnant be with them for a little while
and get out of there and it was like the
idea was the way we smell pheromones if
you're on birth control you smell them a
little differently but the way we smell
pheromones is those those people that
are really bad ideas for long term are
really good ideas for just procreating
they're tall they're strong they have
tattoos they take risks like great but
that's not what's good for me that's
good for this child that we haven't even
had we live so much longer than like
where are like instincts and no animal
urges come from so like we live so much
longer we're like working with different
brains now so like you can't like
you have to like those feelings are
still gonna be there because they're
part of us as humans but it's like
you know um
trying to not be so
hard on yourself fulfilling them and
just like trying to sort of not giving
in to them every time is a challenge and
that's okay like it's it's it's like
part of us so you just have to
um
find a way for you to deal with it so
you don't hurt yourself i guess so end
up in a place where you're not where you
don't want to be
and it's just and it's also like yeah i
think to to make it blameless i think
that what that song doesn't the only
song the other piece you know music
piece that i know of that sort of
conveyed
that in a way that
to me like
made something click
was you know i think to me the greatest
music the greatest comedy the greatest
is when it which is why i bring up
irreversible so much because it changes
you forever like you can't see the world
any other way once you've seen you can't
go back no and and that song i think
part of the reason it was just like the
zeitgeist and is like such a
you know makes your nipples hard when
you hear it frankly um is um
you know the only other song that really
helped me sort of understand the
intangibles of love addiction was um a
case of view by joni mitchell where
you're just like oh right
i could drink a case of you but like i
shouldn't it's that's like the evil
circle of just like going back into that
space where you don't
like i mean you just lose control
basically and i think
that's the hard part because like
sometimes you know when you go through
like a bad heartbreak being in that
state where you kind of have lost
control and you're just kind of letting
yourself go can be so freeing and feel
really like i'm just gonna do and feel
however i want right now because i am
fucking sad doing that because i want to
but then
you have that and then you kind of but
then you get stuck there and then it
stops feeling freeing and fun because
then all of a sudden you're trapped and
then you're in this then it turns into
this
just more more and more darker negative
spiral and start to kind of
you know
hurt yourself in a way and the people
around you because
no one really
can rely on you anymore like your
friends don't see you taking care of
yourself and that becomes frustrating
and it's like and it just that's the
thing too like for me to kind of stay
out of trouble i it's
for the other people in my life who i
know
will be really upset and sad if they
don't they can't depend on me or know
that i'm okay or like know that i take
care of myself and i think that's like
helped me when i get stuck in those kind
of
like
dark sort of moments and like i i don't
know if i've had
that kind of sort of i've been able to
pull myself out of a moment where i feel
like i'm i'm addicted to it like um
but it's but it's definitely with the
help of like the people around me who
are like hey
what's up what are you doing to yourself
and then i can like oh you're right i'm
here again no get out you know right and
but i think that what you did obviously
you were just being yourself and and and
um
organically writing and you know but
you
gave like
terminology to these things that i i
think words are so important i don't
have to tell that to a lyricist but but
the way that we describe ourselves in
relationships i'm heartbroken i'm he's a
bad guy it's like you know you're just
high
and you're going through withdrawals
and he just is who he is he's just bad
for you yeah you know some people can do
drink tequila five nights a week and
then never pick it up again some people
can do heroin once some people it's like
you're just high and and to be able to
have you know women and men have be able
to have those tools to be able to say
like oh no no you're not devastated your
life's not over you didn't just lose
your soulmate you're just strong you're
just withdrawing from your addiction
it's like it's just it's kind of that
simple and you know what i think that
what i know that i've what i do
purposefully is that i've is that i
rarely go
you did this to me i'm mainly singing
about i feel this way because of me or
like what happened to us i'm rarely
blaming the other person for my sadness
or for my heartbreak or for my sort of
just destructiveness that i'm in i'm
just mainly talking about me and my
feelings i've done like made a point of
that
in my music to not
focus put the focus on the other person
the focus is on me me me me me
trust me
that's my focus
i want to ask you about how your husband
proposed if you're willing to admit it
or how you guys came on that
and then in the short film fire fade
which you made in 2017 i believe the
character said i don't want to get
married and be someone's fucking wife
just curious
just curious if that was in your vows
um
just curious if that was sort of your
stance at the time and kind of your uh
evolution when it comes to sort of
commitment and
well so
the funny thing is that we
um it all is kind of connected and it
all happened very fast basically
we
were together we we like we just got
married last year so it's very new um
but we
i knew like i want to be with him for
the rest of my life i don't want to get
married and he's a similar mind said
like i don't need to get married i'm
like i don't really can i just ask you a
question in sweden is is is there's the
kind of after you've been together for
two years in your 30s it's like time to
is there that same timeline that we have
it varies a lot i would say like i have
a lot of my friends have kids and are
not married or just like have been
together for 11 years and just got a kid
and they're not thinking about swedish i
know i know but then i have another
group of friends who are a bit more
maybe traditional and they all you know
two years um then married pregnant like
kind of follow the the usual more
traditional structure but i would say
it's way more common that people aren't
married and just have kids and kind of
live together
we get it you have health care
yeah
pretty much that
um no but so basically i was going to go
to sweden and shoot this movie the
immigrants i was um we were kind of like
unsure you know because of like okay i'm
going to sweden he can't come with me
because uh we're not married i can go to
new zealand what if i can get back into
america we just had all these kind of
feelings of like
just because we're not the proud of the
immigrants
exactly no but we're like why we're not
like it's weird that you know we kind of
have to be connected in that way to sort
of like be able to to
move around the world or like even you
know me
like
if he goes to the hospital like me
you'll be able to go with him like stuff
like that if i
stab him like i did my baby dolls i want
to be able to visit him in the hospital
make sure that he knows that i'm still
watching him
i thought that would be a good way to
keep people's attention i think we
should start going
by the way that's what we sound like
what we're talking about right that's a
whole bucket
hello if you guys know anything about me
you know what i like to
lounge get in bed and stay there
i like to go to bed where i belong
i lay
i lounge i cry i meditate
every couple weeks i even sleep
brooke linen has not only
enveloped me in the cocoon of its love
with its sheets and comforters
now there's a loungewear situation
happening yeah we do love the lounge
road we love it so much that we were
inspired to make our own met gala looks
out of all the other comfy wumpy things
brooklyn's products have you know
we didn't end up getting the invite um
but we did turn some lukes yeah let's
see emily
talk us through your look so the angel
coming at us right now through the grass
is me and um i'm wearing a beautiful
chris angel um nope i'm wearing a
beautiful brooklyn sheet it's soft like
butter and underneath it look how it
flows no and underneath that i'm wearing
the loungewear because it's so
comfortable it's more comfortable than
any kind of you know intimate delicate
undergarment and then underneath that
you're wearing old granny panties from
costco and then under that is my
chastity belt right so um and then i
have my corset okay okay and then um my
capelet and look look at this oh my gosh
i have on this poofy poofy bottom made
out of a brooklyn comforter
that i'm gonna reveal away at the
tearaway
that we have made into a i would say a
pretty uh
cinderella inspired gown here that
really does flow look at it
taking it off over the head oh yeah now
look here now now it's a jacket you're
turning into a jacket okay what can
brooklyn and comforters not do yeah what
can they not do they're turning into a
jacket
we don't even stop there look how cozy
we take a few more strides and then
we're going to lay down for a nap
because we got to sleep we're tired
after all this oh
that's fashion at its finest good night
we're going to bed yes there you go
oh that's me okay that is that is me i
am wearing um because i am
really just trying to lean into the
hollywood sexual predator vibes i'm
wearing a robe right off the shoulder
off the shoulder rolling great great
shit
yeah that outfit of um champion
predators um and then benton made a very
uh uh grotesquely beautiful bra
just get too close to you that's right
big madonna
that's right those are magnificent and
maleficent titans yeah for everyone else
who wants to get glammed up in brooklyn
and they offer bundle deals on
loungewear so you can get more comfort
for less money and if you're looking for
more ways to enhance your comfort check
out brooklyn's candles eye masks and
accessories to properly celebrate your
chill there's a reason brooklyn has over
75 000 5 star reviews and counting so go
on get comfortable and get it for less
at brooklyn and go to brooklyn.com and
use promo code whitney to get 20 dollars
off with a minimum purchase of a hundred
dollars that's b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com
and enter the promo code whitney for
twenty dollars off with a minimum
purchase of a hundred dollars that's
brooklyn.com promo code whitney you guys
always ask me about my skin and why if
my face looks good at all it's because i
sleep and brook linen is the only reason
i can
ah man i can't it's enough with everyone
talking about how great my butt looks i
know i was just thinking that benjen
talks about it constantly well that's my
thing well look my butt
is going places it's it's migrating
north i mean it is thanks to the hydro
rowing machine my butt is what uh the
kids like to call is um
switching oh did they say that they say
your butt you're switching
switch switches
sneaking up on the way with that thing
i walk around and everyone's like is
there was there
for the applause
but we do have a gym here at good for
you which is pretty impressive except
for the fact that none of us really know
how to use anything at all you did a
good job in the gym yeah look at look at
how look at how this team
tries to to
gets the core
there's emily drinking okay
yeah oh no yeah that's not how you use a
treadmill emily you're
now
i don't
you don't even know what that is oh look
he's step dancing
that's not how you use that but hydro we
know how to use yep there's a teacher
explanatory
see hydro no there's no way to mess it
up you can't mess it up no you can't go
wrong they're instructors there are
other people in the same class as you
that are
giving you some help competition good
motivation i need that it's timed so you
can't cheat right you can't get a walk
see to me the hydro is the only
thing that is in the gym that i can use
without getting distracted and going on
texting on my phone and getting on it
you know like right after like one rep
of something i'll just like wander off
and get on my phone and then 30 minutes
has passed right and so you feel like
you're being watched yeah hydro you're
on it and you're in it you have to
exercise there's no way out yeah no
matter how much of a phone addict you
are no matter how like you just cannot
you have to finish it and
i love that there's you know you know
rowlady427
from toledo who's 69 years old who's
beating me right i read that yeah i need
to i need to go
row row
you think you're faster than me yeah
bitch
you're not i like to compete with um
older people that are nailing it i made
my profile is that i'm 70 just to make
other people feel bad that's actually
kind of a genius idea
or make it that you're like 20
to make everybody feel good oh yeah but
i'm not there right you can also do that
i'm not happy enough with myself to make
other people that happy yeah okay good
good very
podcast is brought to you by hydro a
state-of-the-art rowing machine designed
to transform the way you work out named
one of time magazine's best inventions
of 2020 rowing on the hydro works up to
86 percent of your muscles compared with
only 44 from cycling that's twice the
benefit in half the time hydro's
workouts are filmed live outdoors on
waterways around the world from boston
to seattle to miami to london the touch
me tour plus one membership comes with
unlimited profiles for the whole family
and you'll have all the access to live
and honda workouts that include rowing
pilates yoga strength conditioning and
more right now we have a special deal
for all good for you fanatics they are
offering 200
off a hydro rower at hydro.com
folks don't be silly this promo code
won't last long it is only valid through
november and you need
a bubble butt by then thanksgiving is a
common you better pull it together so
you can have some of that gravy and some
of that nog so go to hydro.com right now
and use this promo code whitney that's
hydro h-y-d-r-o-w.com
promo code whitney start making your
exes jealous today you can use promo
code whitney at checkout on hydro.com to
save 200 on the rower a special offer
that won't be around that long
no need to inject cement into your butt
from russia
get the hydro instead
we were just kind of like we started
talking about it and kind of like
joking about it a little bit like maybe
we just need to get married he was like
i'm terrified to propose to you because
you don't you don't like if you say no i
felt there would be a bit of an awkward
moment in our relationship and i'm like
haha no i mean if there anyone that i
could marry be you and we kind of
weren't like we were talking about it as
like is this gonna happen but it was
almost more like a practical
conversation and they were both kind of
like ah maybe we just let this go like
you know but then two weeks later
because i was supposed to leave like in
two months
he just like proposed to me out of
nowhere we were literally
walking up we have this little hill that
we walk up with um our dog and it was
like
so swedish no but this was in this was
here
i know where we go it turns swedish
and there's like um this old log like an
old tree log that you can sit on you
look out all over all of la
and i was just sitting there with him
and i think it was like i was talking
shit about someone that i was like she's
so annoying and me me me
and he was just listening and then all
of a sudden he's like i think this is
the moment i'm like what do you mean
it's like i think this is a moment when
i'm just gonna tell you that you're the
love of my life and i want to be with
you forever and then he said a bunch of
other beautiful things that i can't
remember
and he's just ashamed
do you have your speech to me do you
remember what you said i just no i just
remember that i was like crying like
what what is it happening and i'm like i
didn't know i was gonna like to be
proposed to this much and i was like i'm
so cheesy and i just got really
emotional and then we like laughed and
cried and then yeah we were engaged and
then we're like we kind of have to get
married like real soon should we just
like do it just like a you know kind of
elope thing
and so we decided to go to vegas we
invited um the chapel there obviously
was cover times they're like the little
chat we went to the little white chapel
in vegas and they're like you can have
you can be 10 people total in the little
chapel so we invited our
eight of our closest friends and
we both go you know he got his like
light blue
uh so great
and i have found that my stylist
actually found that um vintage poofy 80s
ridiculous it's just fit me perfectly so
did you write blouse
no
basically wow we wow we basically wow
that i had no idea how to do a wedding
like i was like yeah we booked the
chapel it was like 70 bucks or something
and we booked like a suite at the hotel
our friends came we all we rented dj
gear for the sweet i was like we had the
after party down
but then my friend was like she's like
my roommate jesse she's like oh so we
live with three friends so like it's a
collective in our house so cute yeah
very swedish and she's like she just
like produces big fashion events she's
amazing she was like does she need
fashion yeah she needs something yeah
let me know yeah i'll connect you too
yeah yeah for sure um but she she was
like you
do you have any idea like how do we get
to the chapel from the hotel what do we
do for food i was like i was like well
we can just order like room service
she's like well i look the hotel um
doesn't do room service because i covet
i was like we can just uber she's like
okay can i just like produce your
wedding i'm like okay fine and she like
got this like cute balloon heart thing
she got us a cake which i didn't even
think about she got like she got food
and she got like a big like white
limousine for all of us to write
together which is way more fun than just
like all of us squeezing into different
ubers like an uber pool like one
romantic um but yeah so i got four stars
on my wedding day i'm like come on
uh no but we so we had like on the
friday night we just like kind of all
partied and celebrated they our friends
really cute and kind of did like a
almost like a
bachelor bachelorette party for us that
they just like threw together they wrote
us like a rap song that they all
performed together was really awesome
and i mean we woke up the next day super
hungover the ceremony was until 8 pm so
we were just hanging out all day all
getting ready together and then we just
like got in the car
we're pretty drunk by the time we got to
the chapel it's like this tiny little
white chapel
in the middle of vegas it's the one
that's in the hangover it's that that
one yeah yeah it's tragic yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah so just like the tackiest
thing you can do it's a tourist
attraction
yes
fully that it's a racket and we just
kind of like you know i walk down i
remember i was standing at the door and
like they were all sitting down like my
friends are already crying because
they're super emotional amazing human
beings and charlie's standing at the
front he's like
oh
and the the the minister or whatever the
guy was like officiating the wedding he
was like do you want religious and
non-religious i was like uh charlie
non-religious right
yeah yeah well yeah yeah no yeah no
religion
the guy just he was like we've already
fucked
what would you what do you need i'm
wearing mine i know but because then i
walked down the island it's like you
know 10 seconds of the of the the like
wedding song playing on like a little cd
player and then so we were all kind of
laughing our way through it but then
once we were standing there and he was
like you know he actually was super
funny and said
a lot of just like kind of
cute funny cliches and he would i can't
remember at all what he said because i
was just like am i marrying you right
now
but so and then it got really emotional
actually quite beautiful and romantic
and then it was just like i really felt
like this is so what i want and so yeah
and then we just had
we partied till nine in the morning we
all just dj'd with our friends and dance
and we just like had the best time so it
was actually pretty perfect i mean
our families are like so when's the real
one that does not count
like you know my my mom was trying to
keep it together like very happy for you
and i know it's good that you you're
doing it now but you know i really would
love to be there and i'm like i so
appreciate you trying to keep it
together to not be like why are you
doing this your mom is a therapist and
she's like what did i do wrong
how does it get better than this in
terms of parenting
i know but it was like so we're trying
to plan like doing something where you
know because obviously my family's in
sweden his is in new zealand so like
where do we do it where we can all be
together uh we'll figure it out but
honestly iran it was perfect it's like
somewhere in the middle actually it lays
like the middle east where malaysia is
but i will say it was perfect i loved it
like that's if i
if i could if if i had to get married
which i did
that would be the way
so this is such an ignorant question i'm
realizing if you get married in america
are you married everywhere else
yes but you have to like register it so
like okay
if i'm like
so he we were actually in spain and
charlie actually ended up in the
hospital uh because he got salmonella
which was terrible i'm sorry that i'm
laughing but from something he ate but
it was just
why are we laughing this is so dark
um
he was a good sport though but yeah i
felt so bad for him but but that is
that's actually love if you can watch a
guy be sick and still want to fuck him
yeah
ever since i'm like what consistency is
it today
i do not want to tell you i'm like i
need to know as i know that you're okay
i'm like i just need to put their
fingers up there now so i need to know
what i'm dealing with
but he was um but then
so in spain i was like i'm his wife i
need to like go in with him and they
were like yep they weren't like are you
can we see your marriage license it
wasn't like that so it's like you are
but it's for him to kind of be able to
sort of
i guess you have to sort of register it
still in sweden and new zealand to like
forward to kind of be
like um legit real with them or
something what is going on with your
ring did he propose with a ring or you
did that later we did it later so he had
he designed this with um
with a friend of his who's a jewelry
designer and it's so
see this is the problem this is why i
can never have a relationship i have
such big
genetically modified food knuckles
american women can't fit
because we have gmos in our food and i
ate mostly lucky charms till like two
years ago so i can't even this is what
my proposal is going to be like will you
marry me like yes and it's like
okay i just know and i'm like never mind
i'm too embarrassed
what is this stone it's like a salt and
pepper diamond i think so it's like a it
looks like a little galaxy inside it
it does
right isn't it cool yay um i picked out
the stone he was like do you want to see
what i'm thinking i'm like nah you do it
what a gangster
yeah i love it
and then what is he wearing he's wearing
like a um it's kind of like a
white gold sort of like more simple but
it's like handmade guys are really into
wearing like those like dark black rings
now and i'm i don't i'm like i'm happy
didn't go with no it's a little
little um
it just doesn't feel as i don't know for
some reason stop trying to be cool
there's something cool about this yeah
your life's over yeah it's over you're
married and you've had it right yeah
there's no
joe i'm saying this is not the time
really i'm gonna get a cool ring dude
it's over man
stop trying to like impress girls with
your cool wedding ring like it's our
website that's true it's not cool dude
like that those days are over
stop trying to make this shackle
handcuff
cool yeah exactly not cool you're tied
down yeah totally
so yeah i would have done handcuffs if
it wasn't so kinky okay i have a couple
more questions i just feel like i i have
to ask you that i'm gonna let you go
because i want to talk about bikini porn
yes
this video
gave me a new lease on life
it made me you when i watch your videos
i'm like
i don't i'm not having enough fun
like i literally it makes me want to go
like have fun i watch my new videos i'm
like should i go to burning man like i
it makes me
like she's having the most fun so this
is a video i'm just curious how you made
it because
as someone that is in underwear most of
the time in my home and it really
ends it's going to be a lawsuit one day
you get to just make a music video um
and uh but was that something that was
that was really premeditated or was that
something you shot when you were on tour
no so it was actually
the song was kind of part of you know
like um the sort of deluxe of sunshine
kitty yeah so it's okay this is a really
cool
song that um phineas who i love produced
and really eilish's brother no big yeah
it was like i was like yes i was like
what's big do you like this one and he's
like yeah can i produce it i'm like
yes that's what i hope for which big
wolf in swedish
it's like sarcastically like oh yeah
i think it would be i think it would
almost be like
uh what would it be
oh cool kind of like that it's like oh
cool oh yeah okay so it's more the
delivery yeah you got it i would say
yeah
we don't have our kids we don't have a
friend we don't have a big whoop
i can't think of a i'm sure there is one
but i can't really think of it like
we're not shitty about people's
accomplishments we don't say
we're like congratulations we're sincere
i'm really happy for you i mean it oh
god yeah
um
no but i i um
i think it was it was actually it was so
me and charlie i started working
together at this point and we were i
love working with this um woman monie
hayworth who's an amazing photographer
and she's just this badass british woman
who is um
she's like crazy and cool and awesome
and her she works with this girl clyde
who's also is crazy and cold and awesome
and the four of us were kind of like
what can we do like what like if we need
to do like kind of um
a diy cheap fun video for the song
that's just like you know a weird funny
cool song
and we were just thinking like what if
we just go out
into
victorville for example and just me
running around in bikinis and acting
stupid and mona said would you be down
with that it might be some awkward
moments i'm like i'm down let's do it
that's my brand so we just like
went into victorville with like a little
vhs camera and they just shot me running
around getting up on trucks and like
being awkward around um people sitting
at a bar at 11 a.m who are like please
get out of my face don't talk to me it
was it's such an amazing video because
it's like
you know it it really made me think
because i like to overthink and get
granular and stuff it's like
there's nothing that people want to see
more
than a gorgeous woman in a bikini
but if the gorgeous woman in bikini is
having the best time
she's annoying yeah yeah i'm saying she
can't be having a good time and she
can't be like
not just kind of posing and being sort
of like uh she has to be a little more
like timid and sort of like allude to
the fact that she's like oh you know
that might be a good time i'm not doing
this for your consumption i'm doing this
for my own enjoyment and that is
disorganizing to people
it goes from had you walked into one of
those convenience stores or gas stations
or whatever in a bikini and been like
hey like you know everyone's like stay
as long as you want but if you're having
fun
if a sexy woman is having fun but you're
not allowed
exactly you're not allowed to have sex
with me all of a sudden i'm a nuisance i
remember starting out there's always
that feeling of like
oh you want me to be sexy and i'm i can
hint at that i'm
willing to fuck but i'm not allowed to
actually just want to fucking like i'm
not allowed to be in charge of wanting
that and so
but that's changed a lot i feel like you
know now i feel that it's not as
maybe that's just like you know maybe
still hiding
yeah yeah but but i definitely feel
but i just remember that i'm like why is
it such a big deal that i'm i'm saying
that i want sex like why is that or like
why can't i choose that it has to be
like oh okay you want to okay then i
guess i want to like why is it always
about the other the man deciding when
it's time for me always has to start as
a rape and then i have to come around to
it like why would you want that but it's
like that kind of feeling like
it's not it's not your you as a woman
shouldn't show that you want that
because that's just bad there has to be
a reluctance to it and there has to be a
pointless to it it's like the virgin
whore thing i need to totally hate sex
or
it's your job anywhere in between is too
confusing yeah because then i have to
like look at your face and read your
face and that's exhausting i have to
actually have to ask i need to get to
know you and read social cues and that
sounds exhausting um we uh did not
finish on immigrants so why is this the
first this is basically your first movie
that you're in that someone else
directed right yeah i mean
this is my first like feature film so
i was actually really shocked i was um
just at home in in l.a and i get
an email from my swedish label and
they're like would you be down to
audition for this role and i was like
but that's a real role what are you
talking about so
the movie's based on
one of our like really famous novels
from the 50s um
and it was made into a movie in the 70s
and it's about the swedes who in like
the 1850s migrated to america because of
like
religious oppression like poverty and
uh you know owning everyone was owning
money to the royal family because all
the land was owned by the royal family
and so like um we were really behind in
the industrial revolution so like a
million swedes maybe even more migrated
to america so basically they went by
boats yeah a sailboat um to new york and
then from new york trained to minnesota
and kind of further up that way so
curious why why maybe similar climate i
don't know like easy to grow
easy to farm in sure
so that's basically what so i play one
of the characters it's not the lead but
it's like the second or third female
lead in the movie
um and i play a
uh 30 year old prostitute who is an
alcoholic had a really rough life she
has a 14 year old daughter she um
straight off her
it's always like that it's always like
that for me i'm like do they even want
me to audition those guys no you're the
only person they see for this yes no i
feel like every time i'm like it's good
they ask you it's always
i've done a few other auditions and it's
very usually like you know trashy
addict whores like always and i'm like
cool it sounds sounds right on that's
the best yeah that's the best though
yeah but i like i love the character and
it was like a lot of i mean my audition
tape was terrible i mean director was
even like
there's a lot of work to do here but he
was like i can see it though so if
you're willing to really do the work and
that's right
director yeah he's eric pope he's he's
amazing um
i loved working with him he was just so
um he likes to do really long shots so
like we would do sometimes eight minutes
without cutting in your shorts yeah so
it was really filming not shorts but but
it was her panties look like shorts and
one of them in one of her shorts you
keep thinking about my grandma shorts
you can't stop um nobody and obviously
doing like a uh you know a
period like um
period peace moving like my first as my
first film and like you know my teeth
are brown like they blotch my skin up so
you know kind of get the blood vessels
out dark under my eyes like i look
really like
i've been through it and i just i loved
the character to get to play that it was
such a cool
thing to get to do but it was a
definitely
a really also uncomfortable challenge
like it was a while since i walked into
something not knowing anybody completely
new world not really getting the lingo
of like what things meant
so what does it mean when you say that
kind of take or like you know just not
understanding it all and
acting against like really amazing
established actors
um as well because i i bet they're a bit
like what is she doing here you know
like why is she in this movie or or
they're intimidated by you but that like
it's everyone's intimidated by the other
person for different reasons yeah
it's always that i guess everyone
everyone's always way more secure than
they let on maybe but they were so nice
to me and they really did like take care
of me and help me but it was also
yeah it was hard i was like will i do
this again i think so but it has to be
it's not like i'm gonna go out to every
audition because it's my new calling but
if a role like that comes around i'm
like i'm doing it because it was such a
cool experience did you feel like like
you know you were able to because it's
someone that gets to decide everything
that you sort of say and everything that
comes out of your mouth and how people
feel was there ever certain
i find maybe i'm like just fine being
submissive hot but there's something i
love about someone just tell me what to
do
because i can sort of turn off the
analytical part of my brain as someone
that's like i think probably perceived
as a control freak we like to do
everything ourselves or we just do
but then when someone just tells me what
to do even if i don't agree with it i'm
like
i'm not in charge you're the one that
decides i actually make sense i love
that which i thought i wouldn't i was
like i can't believe i'm well i won't
have a say about what my you know what
my life is
for money uh
but i remember that i i thought i was
gonna feel like uncomfortable with that
but i actually loved it because i was
like i'm new to this i don't know what
i'm doing i'm just gonna do my best and
then he
will just tell me if if it's good enough
he'll say we're done and if not i'll do
it again and i just so it felt really
sort of comforting like giving it my all
but not being in charge of the final
just knowing like i trust you enough to
know that like you got this yeah like
that's the best feeling in the world
when you leave and you're just like i
have no idea if that was good but this
person
yeah is gonna know what to do yeah and
i'm obviously very
nervous about like because i haven't
seen anything i've seen like little
snippets like you've gone in for adr
like no no like not yet i might i feel
like i don't screw my takes the way you
do i don't have to do three months of
voice over later
um but we did i did go back for one
reshoot but then i didn't see what like
was shot before so
about the story yeah it's a drama yeah
it's a drama so it's it's um
the main characters are
well so it's cool because in the books
it's like based on three books and in
those it's very focused on the male
characters but this movie focuses a lot
on the female characters
so the lead character is a woman she's
like
um she's married to a farmer they're you
know starving and they have a lot of
kids she's like
she's um
uh
about to have another baby and i and
they
they lose a child and because of
starvation and so they kind of decide to
go to america
they're from this like small very
religious village i'm from the same area
kind of and she knows
who i am but you know detest me because
i'm everything that a woman shouldn't be
you know
um loud and drunk and a prostitute so
financially solvent yeah yeah making my
own money yeah yeah um
and so so basically they decide to go
this journey uh to america and i do two
but for different reasons so we kind of
end up on the same boat together
and so there's a very like kind of dark
drama but it ends up with you know
us starting new lives in america and
like us during this kind of really hard
journey over we become friends and so
all these kind of things happen along
the way where
um she sees that i'm like a person in
pain and that i'm
you know someone who who
needs a friend and i see that in her too
like you can kind of
start to feel this um
friendship grown like us being like
wanting what the other one has
um but the focus is really on christina
like lead character and she's in it's
from her point of view so she's in every
shot of the movie so lisa call her to
play the lead is like
she did such an incredible job of just
like she was working i've never seen
anyone work so hard like it was
incredible um but yeah it's just it's
just like you haven't seen this word
document i wrote in preparation for this
interview
i have things bolded
i believe
i mean look at all this i see it
most of these words are spelled
correctly
so i trust you i believe you um so you
and her
thank you thank you thank you um no but
then it kind of it's cool to see like i
base i kind of really turn my life
around when i get to america and
um
it will be out like i'm hoping that it
premieres in sweden in december and i'm
hoping that it'll be on streaming like
services with subtitles all around very
soon because i like really want you know
all of my
my friends here like saw me go through
like all the acting classes they heard
me yelling in the morning when i'm like
there's a scene where i stop the train
that's about to leave without me and i'm
like yelling and really like you know
i'm fighting the conductor and it's like
a whole like action scene and they've
heard me like yell every morning for
like two months and trying to get
through that scene
that makes me want to ask you about your
vocal cords because isn't a part of the
reason your
voice is so deliciously velvety raspy
sexy
like
stevie yeah isn't this bad
no it's true like i did have to have i
had vocal cord surgery once um
and it was from overuse like they they
thought it was a cyst but it was scar
tissue that like my vocal cords had bled
and then they'd become like a lump of
scar tissue
yeah really bad um so they're a bit more
sensitive
now after
um after i had the surgery so i kind of
you know i take care of them pretty well
but part of they're like your voice is
always going to be raspy it's just how
your voice is how they move so don't be
scared of that because like the first
two years after the surgery i was like
because it's like retain retraining your
muscles like if you get
if you're running and you like pull a
muscle like it you know it's like
healing that and then you start over and
you feel like
you're like really have to rebuild it
from scratch and that's kind of what
happened like i would try and sing and
i'm like why can't why are they not
strong enough to hit the notes that i
want so it took me like two years before
i felt like i had my real voice back
because it was muscles yeah yeah and so
and it kind of made me relax when the
doctors were like your voice just is
raspy it's how your vocal cords move
they like move a bit like leaky so
embrace it but you just have to be
careful just don't smoke don't do coke
and you'll be fine you want a nightmare
like no more fun
yeah but that's why these are so good
because i don't have to smoke weed i can
drink well i want to talk about this
because
these c-a-n-n for those of you that are
not in states where wheat is legal
move
uh because these are drinks that see i
everyone knows that my i have a very
public struggle with edibles i don't do
edibles i'm too impatient
and
i i um
i need results too quickly like i'll
take them and i'll be like god i'm like
i want to be able to text my accent
another one yeah i'm just like let me
have another one and then i go like oh
this is a dud like it melted and then my
brain starts telling me
that i'm not high enough and i'm wasting
time and then i'll be like oh i'm not
high so i'm just going to work and then
i'll start sending emails and like
i'll start firing people that don't work
for me and it's just like it's such a
bad scene and they're what my rock
bottom i'm waiting for that email you're
fired
if someone would give me your email i
will happily fire you
and
that is a mirror that was the original
mirror from sex in the city that was
carrie's mirror no that michael patrick
king gave to me yes and or else he's so
he says he probably gives one to
everyone uh
from
i
was so stoned one night i had taken five
weed you know it's such a screwed up
thing because in la all the edibles like
have to be like healthy it's like wheat
blueberries
mangoes so i remember eating like five
of those blueberries was this you who's
like so you just ate blueberries for no
reason
i was like it's not working i'm like so
i'm just eating healthy food and not
getting high this is so pointless
and then i hit my head on that went down
and i had like an egg on the side of my
head i was like okay
weed edibles are not where i shine i'm
but these
are
five milligrams of thc
so i only have to drink what 66 of them
a day yeah yeah
five of these packages they'd make you
the it's the best version of just like
yourself
i feel like i'm loved by a secure a man
with secure healthy attachment strategy
i feel pretty
i feel good about myself
and just the negative inner monologue
goes away
goes
how did this happen
well
how did this happen like how did you
mike do i remember like you just moved
to america and you just became a mogul
you got out of that negative
mindset of sweden where they try to hold
you back and dim your light and you came
here and you're just like
i'm a mogul now um no but you know how
it started it's actually it's pretty
funny so luke who is one of the owners
and starters of cannes who is um
amazing person we uh he has also has an
amazing dog which we take care of a lot
he had this bike rental company for
coachella and we rented bikes from it
and when he saw it was me renting it he
was like oh i actually have something
that she might like can i can i give her
a little gift and and
my sister time was like yeah yeah what
do you what do you what do you have he's
like he gave us a six-pack of the little
cans yeah the small ones
and i drank them and i was like
these are awesome awesome wait i don't
need to
because i was like at the time not
smoking weed cause i was like oh it's
really fucking with my voice i just
can't do it
and then i had this and i was like same
thing with edibles like but if i i love
them but if i have one i'm like i'm in
bed and i'm putting coconut all over my
body and i'm eating mac and cheese and i
don't want to talk to anybody i'm
putting mac and cheese all over my body
and eating coconut oil
i do the complete opposite
but i feel like that's the
edibles to me is like i'm in my cocoon
nobody touched me and with these i like
i just had one i was like i feel great
i'm like no anxiety i'm not like i'm not
like my head isn't going in all of the
different places i'm just like
i feel like a little bit drunk but i
didn't even have anything to drink like
this is great
so
i just kept kind of asking him for more
so he's literally just dropped off cans
to me for
for years and then eventually
and we were just kind of like you know
like small talk a little bit and then um
i think it was
actually charlie was like you should
actually invest in this because they're
doing really cool stuff like he was
keeping track of them and i was just
drinking all the drinks and like this
might be a good product because i can't
stop drinking it it never occurs to us
like oh yeah and that was the thing so
then we just um
lou kind of um
offered he was like well would you want
to invest and i was like yeah i would
let's do it and so i did and then it was
like we just kind of started talking
about like it would be fun to do a
collaboration i was like oh that would
be like a very on point like brand for
me to collaborate with
and
yeah and then we're just like and he was
like we love if you kind of we came up
with the flavor together i was like i
want it to be a sexy fruit passion peach
and he's like but we've been wanting to
make an iced tea with like we'd do the
first like caffeinated drink so what do
we do you know fruits that are sexy yeah
yeah when i look at a peach i feel like
i feel like i have it's a great book i
should go to a therapist i'm like i
am sexually attracted to that beach
this i'm having really sick thoughts
what is it and it's so furry and fuzzy
and i like i i can't even eat it with
the butt crackling no i'm like this
feels like i'm just yeah it's like i
start i actually like bite into the butt
it feels wrong yeah this feels wrong but
yeah there are certain fruits that are
just
sexy yeah and like that sounds sexy so
it felt like i feel like passion peach
banana didn't feel laughs
that's like
that's just gross peach banana that's
just like
this fish feels like it's just like a
goo yeah um no but so we came up with
the flavor that's too sexual good
homosexual yeah yeah yeah yeah no no
fluids it's just more like the start of
it yeah
um but yeah so then and then luke was
kind of like would you guys want to make
something that's like a visual to it and
i'm like i don't know about like doing
like a commercial that feels kind of
like he's like you can literally do
whatever you want and i was like okay
cool let's go and then um we kind of
together came up with um like um
uh charlie by the way was like we should
do like a sort of you running around a
house with like a toy gun very obviously
has to be a toy gun and just like kind
of
kind of maybe shoot at some can so like
just like you playing at home with
yourself like just a ridiculous but then
you wear something super
sexy and then we kind of came up with a
sort of tovarella
world
like go go girl
yeah
and it kind of just um and it was with
moni and clyde who did the bikini porn
video so when you have about seven of
these you there are some aliens you need
to get up for sure there are problems
that need to be
um solved yeah we did we shot it at
moni's house and we just like uh you
know very it was just like it was really
really small crew
and
you know i just like recorded the little
pew pew pew
oh
and we were like this just feels perfect
for we don't even know what this is but
it just works perfectly with this drink
and yeah here we are now it's such a
vibe it's such a like magical surreal
like perfectly you because a lot of
times you see artists collaborate with
stuff like this and you're like oh yeah
cause it's hard because you have to
combine your brand with their brand and
you're like
you know if you're like agreeing to do
this collaboration you kind of have to
agree with what the brand wants like you
know so it's like that and that always
becomes a bit tricky to figure that out
but this was just like a it was so easy
organically it feels yeah it feels just
so right yeah i'm gonna ask you uh
another question i have to know
do you have any songs that you haven't
finished that like i know with comedy
like there's certain jokes where you're
like oh like it's just it's not the
right time or i just haven't cracked it
or i just like
you know and then i'll revisit and then
i'll try to do again and i'm like
whether it's what's going on in the
world makes it
trickier to tell the joke or i just
haven't figured do you have any songs
where you're like it's just not finished
and i just i don't know why yeah oh so
many like there's a lot i try i'm kind
of
i think a lot of people do that they
just you know you write a bunch and then
you pick out whatever feels the best but
then maybe you finish the other ones for
the next record or you know but there's
a few that i just can't crack that i'm
like there's so much like good stuff
here but it just doesn't fully make it
all the way and i don't know i don't
know why i just can't find
it might be that i'm too locked into one
part that if i change that then the
chorus would lift but i love that part
so much that i don't want to so there's
like
i'm always kind of like down to turn
over every stone but sometimes you just
have to like
let it go and you have to walk away yeah
walk away for a while and come back to
it works have you ever walked away and
came back and then it just clicked yeah
okay so that so there's sometimes it
takes 10 seconds and sometimes it takes
yeah it can take weeks and years i mean
habits was like that i think i had three
different courses before i finally
figured out like oh wait it's a
heartbreak song it's not like i do
whatever i want song it's like about a
sad time and that maybe i needed some
distance from the moment to like be able
to see that but it took me a long time
to figure out that chorus but i knew
that there was something special
in the verses and the lyrics and just
the tone of it and in the uh
so i was like there's just something
there so i need to i need to figure it
out and i kept kind of just
chipping away at it until i figured it
out it's the only other song in the club
because i go to clubs so much um no it's
it's it's dancing on my own is one of
the songs where you
put your fist your fists are out and
you're like not even going through a
breakup but you're like like here on the
dance floor
it's when it's when people all of a
sudden they're dancing together but then
everyone just has their own thing going
on and they're like in here that's what
that song does it's just like like i'm
in my own music video and then the
song's over and it's so awkward because
everyone was in their own music video
and it's just like
anyway that was like yourself
it's like such a weird one night moment
totally
like it's like it's like you're about to
hook up and like your knee pops and
you're like like you're like like it
just
it's you get so lost in it that it's
embarrassing afterwards yeah yeah like
you're like all my friends just saw a
side of me that i just like they
shouldn't that that was a singing in the
shower moment and i just did it in
public
you know um
uh okay i'm just gonna ask you one more
thing i swear
uh
do you feel like there are any um
musicians
that you look up to that you love that
you feel like are underrated or like who
who do you listen to because there's
certain comedians that comics love and
then that people love and most of the
people that comics love no one's ever
heard of
and so i'm always just curious if they
have music
i mean
i guess it's weird to say like you know
to me
i feel like robin isn't underrated
because the people that love her like
love her but i do feel like she should
be the biggest biggest artist like ever
you know like one of the biggest female
pop artists i listen to indestructible
is my first song out when i run and my
song back and and i i feel like
she
um
she just has that
like since like still does and since
they you know for so long she's like
been able to just like you know like
pave the way for
so many other female artists that are
like you know i just i just think that
she
i i love to see her kind of more more
people like discover her rediscover her
even like you know i think that
yeah but the people that are fans are
like hardcore fans that's what i'm
saying is that people either like who
and then you sing the songs like oh i
know that but when i saw i went sorry at
the hollywood bowl it's very rare that i
go see live music we all dressed up as
her
in like the calvin klein corset and i
have these like stupid leggings on and
like high tops and like and we show up
we're like we're dressed up everyone is
dressed up as robin every everyone so
you're exactly right it's like you know
um
but maybe that's kind of sick too yeah
maybe there's something sick about that
yes you know
and i feel like she she can just
do what she wants yeah and
they will be there for her yes because
there's also a if you
like get down with robin like you have
to be ready to feel some feelings you
have to be ready to confront some stuff
like yeah the way she phrases things
sometimes like oh god that's me or i
thought that like you have to be ready
to get a little bit uncomfortable and
not everyone wants to do that when
they're just like jamming on the freeway
we don't want the emotional dance party
or like they just want to like kind of
but when robin is on robin's in control
of how you feel you don't get to like
change the song or change you know what
i mean you're you're like rolling down
your wall like you're here your hair's
messed up you know what i mean like
there's no
you're sweating
i mean
i went through a break she
single-handedly got me through a breakup
because that um uh call your girlfriend
video which by the way
as much as i love robin never call your
girlfriend and say it was not her fault
as much as i love robin please nobody do
that
to get don't give a reason
don't say you found something new you
know like don't do that um as much as i
love her but um uh that that video where
she it's one uncut she's in a warehouse
dancing in that furry top and she's like
dancing backwards and anytime i would be
in a bad mood i would just i would like
walk around my house like with a lot
like my laundry and stuff and it's just
like the disney lights on just yes if
you dance to a robinson you can't be in
a bad mood it's like impossible to
simultaneously be in a bad mood you like
dance your tears away
really totally
it's like it's like a purge yeah and you
do that it's the kind of thing where
it's like even if i'm not going through
what you're thinking about right now
like i've been there
and i want to revisit it just to sort of
like feel alive and then i'm with it
yeah and then i can like leave it on the
dance floor
i love it and there's something
just magical that's my that's what i
want to do so that makes me really happy
to hear that it does that then it does
that and there's like a catharsis and
there's this really sick feeling that
you've
done work
i'm like i feel like i worked through
that thank you i don't yeah i don't need
to go to therapy i'm fine i just danced
through that
i just like screamed through that i'm
not even dancing through things though i
really do i think i always like i always
when i'm whenever i go to like i like to
go to warehouse raves quite a lot and
that's like then you can just also just
disappear into the music and i really
like go through feelings and like go
through things that i'm like oh that
kind of made me a little bit sad and
like but i'm like dancing but i'm so in
this way yeah but i love it the last
thing i'll say is that after watching
your shorts your short films it is
obviously very clear that you are a
brilliant writer lyricist you write for
other musicians got it got it got it but
it's like you the way that you write
your music
i don't know if it's intentional but
there's a
just enough of a riddley labyrinth
vagueness to the lyrics that it's like
after watching your movies i'm like oh
she knows exactly how to write exactly
what would make this feeling super
specific and clear but she's choosing to
do this in sort of a more um
sort of like florid way so that it's not
so literal it's more prosaic but in such
a creative way and i guess i just get
obsessed with the words people choose
and the emotions that they evoke because
i'm like if it was if that was
any other word it wouldn't i'd stop and
think about it and get literally yeah
should i i i know what you mean and i
think i i do obviously spend i mean i
spend so much time i'm like should it be
an and or should it be you know like
you're like how do i yeah no i really do
and i think i do like sort of to if you
just listen to it you're like i think
the more you listen you notice the
layers of like what i'm actually saying
but the first layer is can kind of i
also want you to take away
from the song with the feeling you want
to feel with that song so it's like
doing that i think there's like a
a way to sort of tell your story but
still letting people have their own
experience whether you're not telling
someone how to feel you just kind of
you choose sit with whatever that song
kind of wakes up in you um
and that's maybe i don't know if how i'm
not like consciously like here is layer
one here's the second layer just kind of
like write what's happening in my head
and then
somehow that kind of ends up being that
sort of layered it's just no it feels
written
down what i'm saying it's like always
feels like in this weird way like stream
of consciousness even though like as
someone that i'm like oh this person has
written this and sung it a billion times
like it is written but it always just
feels so
um conversational and spontaneous and
like kind of raw and not premeditated oh
thank you which i think is is just
i don't know i it's i have i ever give
anyone more compliments
on anything i've ever done i love it
i mean i need it this isn't yeah but
it's but it's just such a breath of
fresh air because i feel like people
forg i mean i just feel like there was
this dearth after you know troy amos and
fiona apple and and and elena said like
all and there's more i know
that i'm missing liz affairs of the
world and whatever that i just like i
feel so lucky that i got to see women
be
emotional and win yeah you know what i'm
saying like we can have rage we can have
jealousy we can have happy moments and
sad moments and like grow and change and
like and
that's just like nor and then i feel
like it's stopped for a while and i'm
the i love britney spears i love
christina aguilera or whatever but then
it went into this like there was a new
wave we're all perfect like the pendulum
went the other way of like away from
sort of this grunge sort of um uh uh you
know like the breeders and garbage or
whatever of like an hole which was my fa
i mean yeah pull that out i mean that
album was like
everything
and to me and um and then it's sort of
the pendulum went the other way where i
felt like there was this perfection
thing and everyone was kind of like used
to be disney stars nothing wrong with
that but i just felt really like it
wasn't your like what you connected to
it made me feel embarrassed and ashamed
that i wasn't that happy all the time i
was like am i supposed to feel like this
like i don't yeah i think that was what
i was feeling too it's like i don't
relate to that what do i do if i'm sad
like and that's i'm not i can't i can't
i don't want to smile the way she smiles
all the time yeah and like i cannot put
on those lashes like it just is sort of
like just a ha and both should exist
like both are valid and there's fantasy
and escapism in music which is great but
to be able to go like oh my god like i'm
not alone and the grace of of being able
to listen to music that helps you
minimize some shame is there's nothing
more medicinal than that and i think
that now what i love about music climate
now is that both can really coexist and
like a lot of other genres can come out
of that so i feel like i i know people
are like oh you know there's no like
everything just there's too much music
out there there's so much games released
but i love that because i think it's
there's a place for
a lot of different kinds of music to to
exist and like be heard and be seen
so i feel like because i also do i mean
i will sing along to any britney
brittany song know every word but that's
not only what i want i want like
things that um
just like
explain like just say how i feel without
um
uh you know trying to fix it or putting
like a band-aid on it and like
go like try to not think about it you
know just like go into your feelings
like i need that music
too and that is what like i i'm now kind
of realizing it took me so long and
again in a 12-step program the whole
point of 12-step programs is to sort of
um uh admit all your secrets all your
deepest darkest the darkest thoughts and
everyone goes yeah me too and then you
go oh i'm not terminally unique i'm not
alone everybody feels this and then you
get to release shame because shame is
the engine of the addictive behavior so
when you just say hey i want to cheat or
hey i'm just dying to do heroin or hey i
hate my kids or whatever like the most
despicable thing and you say it and
everyone goes yeah me too and you're
just like oh i'm not as special as i
thought everyone feels like this all of
a sudden now i'm not the piece of shit i
thought i was and i can release myself
from my own like self-obsession and ego
and yeah and um which is why i was to
talk about our dark feelings too and not
make such a big deal of it they come and
go they're not constantly but it's also
it's it's the shadow self of like you
befriend your negative thoughts
you know befriend them like you coexist
with them like like they're just trying
to protect you and help you they're just
trying to make sense of things and they
serve us really well and i mean you must
be the place where it's like every time
you have a dark thought you're like
that's a hit yeah um
right now in a way that's like no like
your dark thoughts your your gross
desires all these things we pathologize
like this is part of
mental health is not never having it
it's just when you have those things how
do you deal with it how you just like
love yourself through it and allow them
and honor them and let them exist
because i think the the sort of idea
that because you know a lot of us are
only portraying the times that we're
happy we're always putting our best self
out there on social media i always like
you know it's like a self broadcasting
more really and i feel like it's
it's obviously easy to become like
thinking that you're supposed to be
happy all the time and everyone's
chasing that and it's impossible there's
no way even if you do what you love and
if you read someone you love even if you
like have everything laid out for you
perfectly nothing
there's it's impossible to be constantly
happy and chasing that
is very stressful and you'd never be
happy if you didn't have contrast of
what uh
to reinforce you know what that is the
little the little sort of like reminders
just sort of the guard rails or whatever
they keep you in like the game of
operation it's like you're going down to
get the thing but sometimes you hit it
and it's like it just that means you're
like oh great i'm on the right track i'm
not gonna go down there you know and and
and just watching your trajectory of
like being so triumphant of of watching
you know you be open about sort of your
the you know toxic uh not to pathologize
but like sort of like you know um
the relationships we all have when we're
younger the ones that just aren't right
most of them aren't right 99.99 of all
the relationships we're in are not right
yeah because you don't know who you are
yet and you're still figuring out what
it means to be with someone that's how
it's supposed to be yeah first couple
jobs or not jobs you're going to stay in
forever you know and we don't look at it
like i worked at urban outfitters and
i've never like you know you look at it
and you go oh that was part of my
journey you know and the same thing with
relationships and i think that you kind
of have um uh given people the sort of
vocabulary and um sort of the
understanding that it's like i'm not a
fuck-up i'm not sick i just sort of i am
i tried this thing and it just wasn't
for me and like now i get to move
forward and now you're in this like
amazing relationship with someone that
you love and respect and honor and like
and yeah all the like turns and the
falls and the ups and the downs is like
i mean
they're always going to be worth it i
know they're not over now just because
i'm like you know
it's just it's like
they're always going to be there because
of who i am and that's fine and now i'm
like i don't get so
like
scared now like if i'm in like a dark
place or i'm feeling shitty i i can
somewhere in the back of my mind and
know that like this is going to pass so
just deal with it
yeah
that helps me a lot and then i always go
write it down right now write it down
sublimate this into money but also yeah
i think it's it's to me and i it's taken
me so long to learn like just don't make
permanent decisions based on temporary
feelings yeah they're just feelings like
live in them honor them and then if
they're still around a couple days like
let's think about making a decision but
don't just do something sit there you
know feelings make us want to take an
action and i think you've really
popularized and made having feelings
cool
and just sitting in them instead of
doing something about it or you know
whatever and that's something that i
think i think that we've been trained to
believe if you have a feeling you have
to do something you know we watch
romantic comedies it was like if you
feel jealous you go break up the wedding
you know if you if you miss someone you
meet him at the airport like all these
like toxic things it's like no just i'm
gonna be with my feelings these are mine
this is my property it might have
nothing to do with you and just um
taking the personal liability or like
the personal responsibility off of like
i have feelings i must be a monster it's
like no no yeah and like and and kind of
being okay with feeling them and that
someone else might not understand or
like that you're not trying to project
them on to someone else that you can
just
have them and feel them doesn't mean
that it's something you need to yeah
like you need to edit or fix right away
right right yeah just that takes time to
understand i think that's like a hard
thing to because you also obviously
don't want to be in the bad feeling no
one does no but having patience with
yourself when your body is doing
patience yeah that's it but just sort of
like i don't know it's i i made a movie
about sort of like women's feelings and
how we pathologize them and the female
brand yes i watched it oh gosh thank you
that's so weird um all i did was
compromise but i was proud to do it i'm
glad i did but it was sort of like all
about how we call women you know
like hyper vigilant and crazy and psycho
and all these are superpowers and all of
these emotions serve a really important
purpose it's just that now that we're
safe in society we have all these
feelings we don't always know what to do
with and um and honoring them and
praising them and celebrating them
instead of being like these need to be
small or dumb because you have these or
you're crazy it's like you're crazy not
to
i agree you know and
i'm obsessed with you
i'm just with you i really am do you
have any questions for me just kidding
can you imagine
so now the interview starts okay my turn
i just um i'm so happy for you and
charlie thank you
i love that he's yeah i can't play i
mean we're for from a far we're from
as far apart as you can come
my words are going away uh so just a
crazy feeling that we just are so
similar and that we just smash in this
way and i also love sorry last thing i'm
going to say is that
i think we also have this instinct to
hide everything about our past when we
either either meet someone do we want to
trauma bond with them uh because there's
not something real there or we're afraid
of being abandoned and that's our sick
attachment strategy but we want to share
all of our trauma in order to trauma
bond and make the person superficially
close to us or whatever or we want to
hide our past and go like i've never had
anything bad happen to me ever because i
don't want to i'm super stable and just
you know have never had a bad thought
which is like a yuck um but like the
fact that that you know everything you
do is like on the table it really
inspires me because as someone that has
like have never let guys that i've dated
see my stand up or my old specials i'm
like i don't want you to know that i
cheated on this person or this person
cheated on me you know like i
there's something just so freeing about
being like this is who i am and if you
don't fuck with it like
i'm good and now there's something so
cool i'm so happy for you that the
person that
that loves you
loves everything about you because they
know everything about
no he does he does your past
relationships yeah no he
knows everything and loves you anyway
who is this weirdo
that's what i mean he's a weirdo he's
first no i'm joking but there's
something that must just feel so good to
go like yeah there's no secrets there's
no omission no it's all out there so i
literally can't hide anything even if i
was like i would rather he didn't know
this it's already out there so he knows
yeah but i think it's just like just
permission for people to go like don't
hide what happened you if the person if
it's repellent to the person
no it doesn't mean that you will be the
same in this relationship like we i mean
he's shared a lot about himself too also
and it's m i think it's made him more
comfortable to share more about himself
as well so i just feel
yeah he's just amazing he's just amazing
it's getting annoying i know it is his
birthday
june 24th okay so your birthday what are
you gonna do
um what am i i think i might be in i'm
i'm probably gonna be in sweden
um
because i'll be there writing for more
for my album next album
uh i kind of hope that i'll be here
because i know it's the big halloween
weekend yeah so i don't know if parties
are allowed then i want to just have a
big halloween it's halloween what's
spookier than maybe getting covey
once we're all in masks like anyway yeah
i guess we can all remember
i end these very awkwardly but i just
want um to the immigrants is coming out
soon right yes i watch the trailer well
i watched the trailer of the original
and i was like this is a real period
piece
they shot this on film
this is real low-res she just compared
it into this character
no it's coming out um december 25th in
sweden and then i think i'm not sure
exactly but soon after that and on like
streaming platforms around
the world i hope that you guys live here
uh e i get this on ease is where i order
them it's like an app or you can just
order weed stuff ooh i know everyone in
texas is jealous this is why you guys
vote crazy uh you can't just order we
weed your house um sunshine kitty is out
now
what else am i missing there's so many
other things you're working on new music
now which i think i'm allowed to say but
you guys keep this very secretive yes um
i'm working on new music i'm putting
a new album together but i'm gonna spend
another couple months writing to see if
i can push myself even a little further
okay but it's feeling really good if you
need anyone to cause adversity in your
life
so that you have a muse
i'm your guy i'm obsessed with you i i
strongly strongly advise if you guys
have not seen the short films i was very
inspired it made me want to be braver
it made me want to take more risks
um
your music videos are
bizarre in the best most surreal
way and then laugh out loud funny thank
you i love that it made me jealous it
was annoying uh that's when i know i
admire someone when i'm annoyed by their
work and it makes me feel like i need to
work harder so thank you i'd love to be
annoyed by um
and then uh oh last thing i'm gonna say
your friend glad he's gone
also this song is so i love the idea
that there is a song that's not just
about a guy it's about the girl who was
with the guy and getting her back and
that moment when you sort of lose a
friend to someone and
yeah there's like that's another kind of
breakup you know so that like a very can
be very sort of
that's how like friendship ends
sometimes you know like uh someone meets
someone that the your friend doesn't
like and you or someone so you don't see
it and then you change and then like you
drift apart yes like it happens so often
and then you really like that's a really
hard breakup to go through i think like
losing someone that you're really close
to that way also the surrender of going
like there's nothing i can say to you
this is toxic but you need to go through
it like when have you ever told someone
about a relationship hey i think this is
bad for you and they were like oh you're
right i need to book up with them yeah
thank you so so much because you don't
know yeah you don't they're working
through some ancestral trauma some
childhood things like they need to go
through that the same way we need to go
through our toxic stuff so you could it
really reminded me to just lay you have
to lay back and just wait till they come
out of it yeah that's all you can really
do yeah it's true because when you say
yeah when you realize yeah when you say
i don't like that guy it just makes them
further
get into their sitting nancy like no one
understands that yeah like it just makes
it worse yeah makes you feel crazy so so
that's something that um
uh
yeah i was just thinking so much about
like the the reminder of the the
surrender but also do we have to go down
on guys on their birthday
is that a requirement
i learned a lot of things about how to
keep a narcissist
if you want to like take the wrong wrong
take away from that song as you know
what you see in like every like kind of
like
show that's like a little bit sort of
lit trying to be a little bit edgy and
it's always a joke like uh come on are
we doing it tonight like no but it's my
birthday i feel like that's always like
but it's my birthday like the dude
always says that yeah get a hooker
so i just
i feel like that it kind of came from
that sort of thing that it's like
the least um it feels like it you know
the bare min minimum if you think about
like if you're never having sex and like
okay it's your birthday let's fucking do
it yeah you know so it's kind of like
did you at least do that you know but
then it goes into do you let him leave a
necklace which obviously is a lot
different
yeah yeah
yeah if you know you know if you don't
you know yes and did you give it
but then did you give it to his ego you
can nail it you can do it yeah but we
all know it turns into a monocle
because the necklace never lands in
their earrings it's a monocle and now
it's an eye pattern that is an eye
infection and so
just you practice on your own time and
then we'll talk about yeah are you doing
this
you tell me
monster um
i'm obsessed with you i'm so i hope that
everyone that are fans of yours i hope i
got asked everything i tried to ask
nothing that other people kind of asked
on other shows and i feel like we talked
about a lot of different stuff than
usually so that was really fun i just
think about you and i just think like
like endless wisdom
and i just wanted to be able to like
suck it out of you and be a vampire and
hopefully um
uh
you know give people like these awesome
tools that you have without even sort of
actively trying to have them just by
being honest with yourself thank you
i mean i i i would say the same about
you i mean you get awkward
no but you have a lot of wisdom and a
lot of good advice and i love that
you're so vulnerable and honest and just
like whatever's on your mind you say it
and i love that you're not trying to
censor yourself it's great
i think truth is i do try but that's
still the feedback i get
like you don't sense yourself i'm like
yes i do you only knew about me
i love when people like you're so
unapologetic i'm like do i owe you an
apology
like every time someone gives me a
compliment it's always like
people like you don't even care what
people think i'm like yeah i do you're
like i totally do people yeah you know
what i love about you you're not shallow
you don't even care what you look like
you don't care that people hate you i'm
always like oh
okay
look they're just jealous you're
handling this so well here's what i feel
like i get that a lot sometimes they're
like it's so great because you don't
really care like what you look like or
like you don't you don't care like if
people don't like like what you say or
like that you're too much i'm like is
this what people feel i thought that i
was having a you know yeah i thought
people liked me
when someone delivers the news when
they're trying to console you yeah
you're like um did not know that but
thank you so much uh god i could never
do what you do like implying like ah you
just put it all out there you're so
brave
why why am i brave you just go on tv
without makeup look at you just setting
a good example yeah what
oh yeah you're so fearless i'm like what
should i be afraid of yeah what am i
missing
yeah it's a lot it's a lot of that but
you know what
it's this
place to be yeah it's the oldest place
to be i think i'm i'm obsessed with you
i'm inspired it it's very rare that i'm
like
that bitch has balls like it's very rare
that i see something where i'm like that
would scare me and it makes me want to
be more fearless so that that's sick um
i'm actually going to listen back to
this podcast
like i want to hear it i dissociated a
little bit but i'm excited to like
listen back to it you're just such a a
beacon you're just saying i'm excited
too i feel like we got a lot of
we got really into
the like um usually i feel like when i
when i talk about my music and
everything it gets very much into like
um
just talking about other
uh artists that i've written with like
kind of trying to not get more about
could not be about
but getting so into the
why emotions
is everything
you know
that just like i love talking about that
so i'm just so excited to see you
make a sick next piece
happy and in love
because i there is a little voice in my
head that's like god i hope this
marriage crashes and burns so we get a
sick album
lemonade was a very good album
but uh
but but i'm i'm so excited because
you're inspiring me to go like we can
leave the darkness behind we can accept
the gifts that we deserve and that we
work so hard for
and
still be great artists yeah and i think
that's so possible and also
the darkness is like i can tap into that
and i i like
listen to my fears i try not to run too
much from them i like get it's all about
being i think when you let yourself be
vulnerable that the darkness can come in
without being so destructive and i can
use it for my creativity still and i
think that's like a nice place to be you
give it a voice you give it a seat at
the table without letting it run your
life yes yeah
do you want that do you want to take
that i'm taking that do you want to use
it
that is my favorite thing to do to like
musicians because whatever as a comedian
whenever someone will like come up and
tell the first line of like songs
they'll play the most boring story ever
and then they're like
you can have that
like can i
oh
like it's sitting right here
um i i love you guys do not write
elephants um
you're welcome
how do you say don't write elephants in
swedish
reading to elephant
that's swedish
i love you guys don't write elephants oh
yes thank you thank you thank you thank
you thank you so much for having me
you're a dream